SKINNER COULD COME TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GET STARTED UNTIL
THEN. CONTINUE TALKING AMONGST
YOURSELVES
. WE DO A VERY GOOD
ALL RIGHT WELL GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WELCOME TO THIS
MORNING'S HEARING OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY BUT
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO HONOR OUR LEAD
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT. LISA
HAVEN'T JIMENEZ- LISA HAS
SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE VERY
WELL FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS
AND HELPED ME TREMENDOUSLY LAST
YEAR MY FIRST YEARS CHAIR BUT
SHE WILL BE LEAVING US WE ARE
VERY SORRY TO SEE HER GO- SHE'S
TAKING A DIFFERENT POSITION AND
WE NEVER WANT TO. INHIBIT
PEOPLE FROM MOVING ONWARD AND
UPWARD YOU WILL ALWAYS HAVE A
PLACE IN OUR HEART ALYSSA THANK
YOU SO MUCH- SO JOIN ME IN
WISHING HER WELL. ALRIGHT I SEE
THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE
WILK PRESIDENT WILL CARE CHIANG
CHAIN HERE THE RUSSELL. RUSSELL
HERE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN. WE
HAVE A QUORUM MEMBERS- WE ALSO
NEED TO ADOPT OURPROPOSED
CHANGES AND OUR COMMITTEE RULES
ALL MEMBERS WERE PROVIDED WITH
A COPY OF THE COMMITTEE RULES
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE RULES ALL RIGHT IF THERE
ARE NO QUESTIONS- IF SOMEONE
COULD I MAKE A MOTION TO ADOPT
THEM SO MOVED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WILK MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE WELL HI WILK I CHANGE
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN. PAN HI VERY
GOOD THE RULES HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED BUT WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO VOTE
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO START WITH SB SIX SEVENTY
THREE BY SENATOR MORALE SENATOR
MORALE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HIM
MEMBERS- FOR BEING HERE EARLY
BRIGHTON EARLY DAY YEAH I JUST
WANT TO ISSUE A COUPLE OF
THINGS- THOSE LETTERS THEY CAME
MAN JUST THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. THAT WAS
JUST OVER THE WEEKEND AND WE I
HAD SOMEBODY COULD TELL A
STATE- DROPPED OFF SEVEN TO TEN
THOUSAND LETTERS AT THE-
EDUCATION. COMMITTEE YESTERDAY
AND THEN THOSE BOXES OVER THERE.
SO LET ME HELP ALL OF YOU IN
THE AUDIENCE YOU MUST BE NEW WE
DO NOT A PLOTOR BLUE IF YOU
LIKE SOMETHING YOU CAN GO LIKE
THIS IF YOU DON'T LIKE
SOMETHING YOU GET TO STAY
QUIET. SEVERAL PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU- AND IN THOSE BOXES
OVER THERE WHAT WE DID IS WE
WERE GOING TO PRINT OUT THE-
FOR ALMOST FIFTY THOUSAND
PETITIONS. BUT BEING A
CONSERVATIVE WE DIDN'T WANNA WE
WANT TO BE CAREFUL OF- STATES
MONEY SO- MY STAFF SPOKE TO THE
PRINTING OFFICE AND THEY SAID-
THAT'S HOW MANY BOXES IT WOULD.
TAKE TO FILL THOSE ALMOST FIFTY
THOUSAND AND SO ANYWAY AS YOU
CAN SEE- THAT THAT'S JUST A
SMALL PORTION OF THE LETTERS WE
HAD. BUT ONE OF THE THINGS SORT
OF TOUCH MY HEART IF YOU LOOK
TO THOSE THOUSANDS OF LETTERS
THEY'RE NOT FORM LETTERS. THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY HAND
READY TO YOU KNOW BECAUSE
BECAUSE IT THIS GOES DEEPER YOU
SEE. THE JUST THAT- YOU KNOW
MONEY IT'S ABOUT OUR CHILDREN
AND SO THAT'S WHY I THINK
THEY'RE SUCH A VESTED INTEREST
IN HERE AND WHY PEOPLE POURED
THEIR HEART OUT. MOST THOSE
WRITTEN TO ME BUT THEY WERE I
TOOK SOME OF THE ZIP CODES.
THAT YOU GUYS RAN AND- SO I
KNOW I SOUND I THINK THREE
THOUSAND LETTERS TO YOUR OFFICE
SENATOR- THAT ZIP CODE SO
ANYWAY GOOD MORNING CHAIR. IN
MEMBERS- I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO SAN SB SIX SEVENTY
THREE ON BEHALF OF- THOUSANDS
OF PARENTS WHO ARE OUR STATE-
PETITION AGAIN I. PUT HOW MANY
THERE WAS THERE BUT ALSO WE
HAVE A DIVERSE GROUP THIS.
CROSSED PARTY LINES. I GUESS
KIDS WILL BE THAT. FOR
CONCERNED PARENTS RIGHT AND
ORGANIZATIONS- BUT OF OVER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CITIZENS- WE'RE FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF I COULD GO
ON BUT I JUST NAME THREE
QUICKER- THIRTY HISPANIC
CHURCHES HAVE SIGN ON. THE A
LIST- ISLAMIC COUNCIL SEVEN
CALIFORNIA WITH OVER SEVENTY
MOSQUES. AS WELL AS OTHER
MUSLIM ORGANIZATIONS. ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THE
PEOPLE'S BILL AND- WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THE CATHOLIC SIGN
ON WITH THEIR TEN MILLION-
PARISHIONERS AND ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS REPRESENTING OTHER
CHURCHES. ALSO I AM GRATEFUL
FOR THE SUPPORT. OF THE
SOUTHWEST SECTION OF THE AND
DOUBLE ACP WHO SAYS WE SUPPORT.
SB SEVENTY THREE BECAUSE IT
CURRY- INCREASES PARENTAL
OVERSIGHT. WITH AN OPT IN FOR
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS- IT. THE
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE ALSO SAYS
WE ADVOCATE FOR THE HIGH
QUALITY OF EDUCATION. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS ATTENDING
OUR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SCHOOLS-
IN DOING SO WE AFFIRM THE
PARENTAL RIGHT. TO DIRECT AND
BE FULLY ENGAGED IN THEIR OWN
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION. AND FROM
THE ISLAMIC COUNCIL. THEY PUT
AS YOUR CONSTITUENTS. CAL. HI
VOTE SB SIX SEVENTY THREE SO
THE ATTENTIONS OF PARENTAL
INVOLVEMENT PRESCRIBED IN STATE
LAW CAN BECOME REALITIES FOR
GATE GRADES K. THROUGH SIX IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THIS
ISSUE STRIKES A CHORD WITH
PARENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA WHO
CARE DEEPLY FOR OUR YOUNG
CHILDREN AND WHO WANT TO BE
ACTIVELY ENGAGED AND INFORMED
ABOUT- INSTRUCTION IN OUR
CLASSROOMS TO BE CLEAR SB SEVEN
SIX SEVEN. THREE IS ABOUT OUR
YOUNGEST STUDENTS ARE K.
THROUGH SIXTH GRADE OUR FIRST
SECOND THIRD FOURTH AND FIFTH
GRADERS. AND BETWEEN- IT THIS
BILL DOES THREE THINGS IT
CREATES TRANSPARENCY. IN FULL
DISCLOSURE. BY REQUIRING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE POST THE SIX
CLASSES- CURRICULUM ONLINE
MAKING AVAILABLE FOR PARENTS TO
REVIEW WHAT A CONCEPT. IT ALSO
ENSURES PARENTAL PARTICIPATION
ON THE SENSITIVE TYPE TAKE A
SPECIALLY TO ARGUE NO YOUNG
FIRST SECOND THIRD GRADERS- BY
REQUIRING AN ACTIVE- OPT IN
POLICY- TO ANY SEX OUR CLASS
LESSONS THAT THEY HAVE IN
REQUIRES A SEXUAL HEALTH AND
HIV PREVENTION CURRICULA TO BE
AGE APPROPRIATE. IN MEN
PARTS OF STATES PARENTS HAVE
BEEN STONE WALL WORDS HAVE
GOTTEN QUITE A BIT A- PHONE
CALLS ON THIS AND EXAMPLES BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- FOR SOME
REASON THEY THEY DON'T WANT
FULL DISCLOSURE AND THAT'S NOT
MY WORDS THOSE ARE CALLS AND
LETTERS OF WE'VE HAD COME IN
AND SO THAT ALWAYS GVES THE
APPEARANCE. OF HIDING SOMETHING
BUT ALSO I JUSTWANT TO THANK A
COUPLE THINGS- THE ACLU SAYS
PERCENT IN IN A OPPOSITION
LETTER TO ME BOB AND THE REASON
I JUST WANT TO SHARE A COUPLE
THINGS FROM IT IS A SAY THAT
THIS BILL RUNS COUNTER TO THE
BEST BEST BUSINESS PRACTICES.
AND IT'S KIND OF FUNNY ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THEY CITE A STUDY
FROM THE RAND INSTITUTE FROM
OVER THIRTY ONE YEARS AGO. THAT
THEY THINK THE BEST WAY. TO
GIVE PEOPLE NOTICES THROUGH
MAIL BUT YOU KNOW SINCE THE
LAST THIRTY ONE YEARS WE NOW
HAVE WE'VE BEEN ADVANCE IN
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY SO MAYBE
THEY SHOULD COME UP TO SPEED
WITH THEIR BETTER BUSINESS
PRACTICES BOB AND SO WHAT
HAPPENS BECAUSE WE HAD EMAIL
SALES TAX- WHATEVER YOU YOU
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO CLEARLY
COMMUNICATE PERRANCE. AND SO
THAT WAS KIND OF A WEIRD THING
THEY SAID BUT WHAT IS WORSE
ABOUT THE STUDY THAT THEY SITE
FROM THE RAND INSTITUTE IS THE
SAMPLE SIZE WAS TO SEVENTH
GRADE CLASSES IN LA. SOMY-
STAFF DID RESEARCH AND WE FOUND
OUT THERE'S TEN THOUSAND. FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE SCHOOLS
IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND BACK
THIRTY ONE YEARS AGO THEY ONLY
SAMPLE TO. A CLASSROOM SO THAT
WAS THE ACLU'S LETTER AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR MAKING A
CASE. PHAM CONNECTS I'D LIKE TO
READ ONE AND THIS IS KIND OF A
SAD WHEN I'M I CAN READ THE
WHOLE THING. BUT I'M I'M VERY
DISAPPOINTED- I LOVE TEACHERS.
YOU KNOW THAT SEVEN YEARS IN
HIGH SCHOOL I GOT TO KNOW MY
TEACHERS PRETTY WELL- BUT THE
FEDERAL CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS. SAN IN A LETTER
OPPOSING TO AN AND THIS THIS
THIS IS PROBABLY MORE ON A
SERIOUS NOTE. BECAUSE WHAT THEY
SAY THEY SORT OF MAKE OUR CASE.
THIS OPPOSITION LEADER WARREN
OPPOSITION TO SAID SIX SEVENTY
THREE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE FOR A
PUPIL IN ACTIVE PARENTAL
CONSENT. WITH A SIGNATURE. FOR
SEXUAL EDUCATION. SO THEY DON'T
WANT THE PARENTS TO SIGN IN IT
JUST KIND OF WHATEVER BUT IT
ALSO SAYS. THIS BILL REQUIRES A
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO MAKE THOSE
MATERIALS AVAILABLE FOR
INSPECTION. BEFORE THE DATE OF
INSTRUCTION. AND SO AGAIN I
DON'T KNOW WHY THEY THEY WOULD
WANNA WANNA HIDE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS BUT BUT WORSE THAN THAT
THEY PUT IN THIS LETTER AND
AGAIN HIT IT'S SORT OF- THE I
THINK IS BAD BECAUSE ARM. AT
ONE TIME THEY BELIEVE THEY WERE
PUBLIC SERVANTS AND I AND I
STILL BELIEVE THEY BELIEVE THAT
PROBABLY THE MAJORITY THE
TEACHERS BUT THIS LETTER. SORT
O INCRIMINATES HIM- ON THIS
BILL SAYS IT ALLOWS PARENTS TO
REVIEW THIS IS WHAT THEY'RE
AGAINST THIS RIGHT THIS OFTEN
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS PARENTS TO
REVIEW THE INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
BE POSTED ON THE DISTRICT'S
WEBSITE. INCLUDING TEACHERS
LESSON PLANS AND SCRIPTS
THERE'S MORE TO THIS LETTER.
BUT I THINK YOU GUYS HAVE HEARD
ENOUGH AND YOU GET THE POINT
THAT I'M TRYING TO MAKE. BUT
ANYWAY- FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH STEP.
POSTED A I THINK OUR ARGUMENT-
IN IT TOOK US ONE MOTHER BY THE
WAY AND SHE'S HERE TODAY JUST
IN CASE IT NOT. TO TESTIFY BUT
JUST IN CASE OF ANYBODY ON THE-
DíAS WOULD LIKE TO ASK HER
QUESTIONS- IN THE EAST BAY ONE
MONTH. AND SHE'S NOT THE ONLY
ONE THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT. WHO
PRESTON HER SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND OFFICIALS. AND IT TOOK OVER
ONE MONTH BEFORE SHE WAS GIVEN
PERMISSION. TO GO DOWN TO THE
SCHOOL AND THEN AT THAT TIME
THEY ONLY GAVE OUR HALF HOUR TO
REVIEW HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF
MATERIAL. AND SO THIS IS WRONG
PARENTS SHOULD BE THE PRIMARY
DECISION. MAKERS AND WHEN AND
HOW THEIR CHILDREN ARE
INTRODUCED TO SENSITIVE
MATERIAL. NOT OF COURSE
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATS
HOPEFULLY WE ALL BELIEVE THAT.
AND THAT'S WHY WE WANT
EVERYTHING. OUT IN THE OPEN AND
BY THE WAY. POLICY THAT FOR
LATER I AM AWARE THAT SOME
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL CENTERS
AROUND AN ACTIVE OPT IN POLICY.
BUT THIS IS WHAT FAMILIES ONE.
AND THAT'S WHAT SB SIX SEVENTY
THREE DOES SIMPLY IS LIKE A
PERMISSION SLIP. AND IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE IF YOU TAKE
A FIELD TRIP. YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A PERMISSION SLIP RIGHT. BUT
YOU KNOW THAT SOME OF THE MOST
SENSITIVE SUBJECTS WERE NOT
DOING THIS FOR OUR CHILDREN.
AND YET. AGAIN WE DON'T WANT TO
CUT THIS IS THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE IT SEEMS LIKE
WE'RE CUTTING PARENTS OUT OF
THE LOOP IN EDUCATION. AND
THAT'S NOT GOOD BECAUSE-
RESEARCH SHOWS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WHEN PARENTS ARE
INVOLVED. WHETHER IT'S MATH
SCIENCE AND LITERATURE. OR
SPORTS THEIR CHILDREN ALWAYS
PERFORM BETTER SO WE SHOULD
GIVE PARENTS FULL ACCESS FULL
DISCLOSURE SO IF PERMISSION
SLIPS ARE REQUIRED FOR MUSEUM
TRIP OR A FIELD TRIP- BECAUSE
WE NEED THE RELEASE OF
LIABILITY TO INFORM THE PARENTS
WHERE AND WHENTHEIR CHILDREN
ARE GOING TO BE- THE WANT TO
TRIP SURELY WE CAN ASK THE SAME
FOR SEX. FOR THE SIX CLASSES
AGAIN FOR OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS
FIRST SECOND THIRD THROUGH
SIXTH GRADERS- IT'S A TOPIC
THAT NEEDS PARENTAL
PARTICIPATION- SIX SEVENTY
THREE ENHANCES SUPPORT FOR
PARENTS AGAIN THIS IS ABOUT
PARENTS NOT GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY FOR PARENTS WHILE
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY AND SS
ABILITY THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT ME YOU'LL HEAR FROM A
NUMBER PARENTS AND FAMILIES FOR
THE TRAVEL ACROSS OUR STATE TO
BE HERE I'M GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND WANT TO THANK THEM
FOR MAKING THIS TRIP ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE MEMBERS TODAY. FOR
BE INHERENT LISTENING TO THIS
BILL WHAT'S A SENSITIVE SUBJECT
BUT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
LAST YEAR I BOWED BUT HERE TO
TODAY I'VE GOT A COUPLE OF
SPEAKERSTEAM BROYLES WHO'S
PRESIDENT AND CHIEF COUNSEL FOR
THE NATIONAL CENTER WHAT I'LL
SEE AN A DOCTOR SOBEL WHO I
JUST MET BUT I TALKED TO HIM
NUMEROUS TIMES ON THE PHONE AND
I WE HAVE KINDRED SPIRITS HE
SAID. THE ISLAMIC COUNCIL OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU SEVERAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE USUALLY TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES. PERCENT.
GOOD I ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT WHAT
I SAID. WHICH I PROBABLY DIDN'T
MAKE CLEAR START IS WE'VE GOT
TO WITNESSES RIGHT HERE SO
THEY'RE GOING TO WITNESS BUT
WHAT I HAD MENTIONED IN CASE OF
ANYBODY UP ON A DíAS DID HAVE
A QUESTION FROM A CONCERNED
PARENT- BECAUSE DENISE'S
SOMEONE IS SORT OF GOT THIS
BILL STARTED WAS HER IDEA SHE
FROM THE BAY AREA SO IF YOU DID
HAVE A QUESTION FOR. SHE WOULD
BE HERE MY MOM THAT YOU PERFECT
SO TO WITNESS TWO MINUTES EACH
ALL YOU DECIDE WHO GOES FIRST.
GOOD MORNING. I'M HERE IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ATTORNEY.
HUSBAND OF A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER AND FATHER OF THREE
TEENS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SEVENTY THREE. US SUPREME COURT
HAS REPEATEDLY AFFIRMED THE
PARENTS HAVE THE FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT. TO DIRECT THE CARE AND
RAISING THEIR CHILDREN NOT TO
STATE. FAMILIES DO NOT LOSE
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AT
THE SCHOOLHOUSE GATE.
CALIFORNIA'S YOU YOU THE%
ACKNOWLEDGES PARENTAL RIGHTS BY
PERMITTING BUT NOT REQUIRING
THE CSE INSTRUCTION BE GIVEN K.
THROUGH SIX GRADES. THE
PROVIDES FAMILIES OF THE OUR
ABILITY TO OPT OUT NGUYEN CSE
IS TAUGHT MIDDLE SCHOOL AND
HIGH SCHOOL AND REQUIRES YOU
SEE MUST BE AGE APPROPRIATE
MEDICALLY ACCURATE. SB SIX
SEVENTY THREE FURTHER ENSURE
THE PARENTAL RIGHTS ARE FULLY
RESPECTED IN SEVERAL IMPORTANT
WAYS FIRST TRANSPARENCY SEE SEE
TRANSPARENCY IS CURRENTLY A
REAL PROBLEM BY ORGANIZATIONS
RECEIVED MANY COMPLAINTS FROM
FAMILIES FACING SIGNIFICANT
BERRIES AND ASSESSING AND
REVIEWING SEXUAL HEALTH
CURRICULUM. UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA IF YOU TAX IF TO
SCHOOL IF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
DECIDES TO TEACH SEXUALITY
HEALTH CURRICULUM. YOUNGER
CHILDREN K. TO SIXTH GRADE SB
SIX SEVENTY THREE REQUIRES THEM
TO MAKE THE ENTIRE PROGRAM AT A
LEVEL. SITES IN LANGUAGES
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES CAN
UNDERSTAND. CONSENT REQUIRES
THAT PARENTS ARE ACTUALLY
INFORMED. THIS BILL REMEDIES
THIS DEFICIENCY SECOND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CHOICE
COUPLED WITH TRANSPARENCY IN
ACTIVE OP IN IS A MUCH BETTER
SAFEGUARD OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
INCLUDING PRANA RIGHTS IN THE
FREEDOM OF CONSCIENCE APPLYING
THE PASSIVE OPT OUT HERE WOULD
MEAN THAT VERY YOUNG CHILDREN
MAY BE SUBJECTED TO SEE A SCENE
MATERIALS AGAINST THEIR PARENTS
ACTUAL WISHES. SB SIX SEVENTY
THREE MAKES CALIFORNIA WHO HELP
THE ATTACK MORE CULTURALLY AND
RELIGIOUSLY SENSITIVE AND IS
BETTER RESPECT CIVIL RIGHTS.
AND THE CORE LIBERAL VALUES OF
TOLERANCE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSIVITY. INFORMED CONSENT
REQUIRED TO INFORM PARENTS
ACTUALLY GIVE CONSENT.
SIGNIFICANTLY THE RESEARCH
CITED BY THE ACLU AND MOST OF
THE OPPOSITION LETTERS DOES NOT
SUPPORT THE ALLEGATIONS THAT
OPT OUT IS PREFERRED BY
PARENTS. NOR THAT VERY EARLY
SEXUALITY EDUCATION IS IN THE
BEST ITERESTS OF CHILDREN. THE
OPPOSITION RESEARCH ACTUALLY
SUPPORTS SB SIX SEVENTY THREE
THE RAND STUDY IS POINTED OUT
STRONG SUPPORT ON FORMED SENT
HERE CONSPIRACY AND OFTEN. CSE
STARTING IN FIFTH GRADE AT THE
EARLIEST NOT KINDERGARTEN OR
FIRST GRADE WITHOUT THESE
ADDITIONAL SAFEGUARDS OF
TRANSPARENCY. ACCOUNTABILITY
AND CHOICE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL BE MORE
VULNERABLE TO FINANCIALLY
CRIPPLING CIVIL RIGHTS LAWSUITS
FROM FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN HARMED BY THESE EARLY
SEXUALITY PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED. A
GOOD MORNING TO RESPECT IT
SENATORS MY NAME IS DOCTOR I'M
IS SO ON THE CHAIRMAN OF THIS
LONG MAKE SURE COUNCIL SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AN UMBRELLA
ORGANIZATION OF SEVENTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONSREPRESENTING OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
I'M ALSO THE REGISTER TO THE
CHINO VALLEY STOMACH CENTER IN
THE CITY OF CHINO I'M A DENTIST
ON FATHER I'M A CONCERNED
CITIZEN AS WELL. I'M SURE MAKE
A DECISION ABOUT WHAT THE FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS NOT IS TOO
COLD BUT I'M SURE HE'LL TAKE
EVERYTHING EVERY MAJOR YOU CAN
IN EVERY. EFFORT YOU CAN'T TO.
DO THE BEST AND CHOOSE THE BEST
DECISION TO PICK THE BEST
CONCLUSIONS FOR OUR COMMUNITY
AND OUR STATES REGARDLESS OF
YOUR POLITICAL AFFILIATION. I
WOULD LIKE TO SHOW MY
COMMUNITIES PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
MATTER. WE ARE A DIVERSE
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE DIFFERENT
CULTURES DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS.
DIFFERENT ETHNICITIES BUT WE
ALL AGREE ON ONE VERY IMPORTANT
THING. WE AGREE WITH ALL THE
PARENTS IN THE WAR HAT WE LOVE
OUR CHILDREN. WE LOVE THEM
TREMENDOUSLY. SOME ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THE GENUINE REQUEST
AND THEY MOTION PLEASE
APPEARANCE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THESE PARENTS ARE
CONCERNED THE SPIRITS ARE
AFRAID. THESE PARENTS ARE
WORRIED FOR THE MOST VALLEY
LASSES THE HACK WHICH IS THEIR
CHILDREN. WE ARE FORTUNATE TO
LIVE IN A NATION THAT PROTECTS
THE RIGHTS OF ITS CITIZENS
INCLUDING THE RIGHTS OF THE
PARENTS. ONE OF THESE. THE EACH
FATHER MOTHER WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE. INVOLVED IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION. SOMETHING
NOT ONLY BENEFITS CHILDREN. BUT
ALSO THE SITE YET LARGE. THE
CRISIS WE HAVE IN THE WAY AWARE
YOUTH AND YOUNG STARS ARE
ACTING. IS VERY SERIOUS AND
VERY CONCERNING. THESE ARE OUR
FUTURE SENATORS FUTURE LEADERS
AND FUTURE PRESIDENTS. THE MORE
WE STRIP AWAY RIGHTS FROM
PARENTS. THE STILLER SUFFER AND
OUR NATION AS WELL. AMERICAN
LISTEN TO JOIN. HANDS VERY WHAT
IT MEANS TO BE DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST. FOR THE MOST FROM
BEING A- PLACE IN SCHOOL. WE
ARE ALL FOR CREATING MET. TO
MAKE THINGS BETTER. BUT THE
MEASURES WE TAKE HAVE TO BE
BASED ON THE CONSTITUTION
RIGHTS. SCIENTIFIC FACTS AND
FAMILY VALUES. WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT INCREASES
PARENTAL OVERSIGHT. WITH AN OPT
IN FOR OUR KIDS AND INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY. AT MY DENTAL
OFFICE WHICH IS BY THE WAY IN
THE SAME BUILDING AS- SENATOR
LEVERS OFFICE IN POMONA. OF TO
COME OVER AND SAY HELLO. I
CANNOT CLEAN KIDS TEETH WITHOUT
A VERY DETAILED CONSENT SIGNED
BY ONE OF THE PARENTS EVEN IF I
HAVE TO PROVIDE WITH DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES. I'M SURE CLEANING
THE TEETH OF A TEN YEAR OLD BOY
OR GIRL IS MUCH LESS SERIOUS
THAN TEACH THEM ABOUT SEXUALITY.
WHEN YOU VOTE ON THIS BILL
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THAT THE
MORE WE ONLY MAKE PARENTS THE
MORE WE'LL SEE EXODUS FROM THE
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. INTO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND INDEPENDENT
SCHOOLING WHICH IN TURN WILL
HURT OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
IN THIS PERSPECTIVE I SURE THE
VOICES OF THE MOST OF
COMMITTEES OF CALIFORNIA AT
LARGE NORTH AND SOUTH AND
CENTRAL. AND ALSO THE VOICES OF
EVERY CONCERNED PARENT. WHO IS
NOT ABLE TO SHARE HIS OR HER
VOICE TO YOU AT THIS CRUCIAL
HEARING. AS YOU CONSTITUENTS
THEY ARE ALL SAYING PLEASE
SUPPORT OUR PARENTAL RIGHTS AND
VOTE I TODAY THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND FOR BEING TRUST
WITH THE PUBLIC SERVANTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE GO TO YOUR PHONE AND
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION
HAVE ONE AND IF YOU. PORT THE
BILL. MY NAME IS CRAZY
VANDERMARK IN I'M A PARENT TO
FINANCE COMMISSIONER FOR THE
CITY OF HUNTINGTON BEACH AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
KELLY XIN HUSKY I'M A RESIDENT
OF MONTEREY COUNTY I'M A MOM OF
TWO CHILDREN AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS BISHOP CHRIS
BAKER RESIDENTS SACRAMENTO ON
EDUCATION ADVOCATE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY ANSWER FERNANDES
SACRAMENTO NATIVE AND POLITICAL
GRADUATE IN SUPPORT. KAREN
ENGLAND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE
SUPPORT SB SIX SIX SEVENTY
THREE. GINA GLEASON WITH REAL
IMPACT BASED IN CHINO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MY NAME
IS TIME AT BERKELEY I AM A
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER IN
THE ROCKLIN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS MICHAEL BAKLEY
I'M A FATHER AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. PASTOR JENKINS COVERAGE
CHAPEL CHINO HILLS TEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BY THE WAY THAT'S MY PASTOR I
JUST WHICH YOU GUYS NEVER.
ALLOWED I LOVE THAT GUY.
AMERICA FORGET- I'M FROM THE
COACHELLA VALLEY MOTHER OF FIVE
REPRESENTATIVE TO ALLIANCE TO
PROTECT CHILDREN AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MY NAME SEVEN
FEDERAL AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
PASTOR TIM THOMPSON FOR TWELVE
CHURCH AND ALSO DIRECTOR OF OUR
WATCH I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STEPHANIE AIDS MOM OF THREE AND
FOUNDER MEAN FOR PARENTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. LISA DOES BROKE VETERAN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER AND BILINGUAL TEACHER.
HERE IN THE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RENDON LEAD SAKSI T. A MEMBER
ANY A MEMBER CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION MEMBER AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
SIX SEVEN THREE AND PARENTAL
RIGHTS THANK YOU. MICHELLE KNEW
FROM ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
TWO CHILDREN A PUBLIC SCHOOL
AGE I STARTED TEACHING AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WHEN IT
SELLS DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR LIFE WITH MEMBERS IN EACH
OF YOUR SENATE DISTRICTS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
RICHARD WORKMEN ALLAIRE TO
PROTECT CHILDREN. BETTER OF THE
TWO WARS GRANDFATHERED EIGHT
CHILDREN AND I STRONGLY PROCESS
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARYLAND JACKSON PRAY FOR SAFE
SCHOOLS TO PROTECT AND DONE. OF
SECURE OUR STUDENTS RIGHTS IN
OUR PARENTAL RIGHTS AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MICHAEL
KELLY FROM SAN LEANDRO
CALIFORNIA- A FATHER AND I
REPRESENT UNIVERSAL PEACE
FEDERATION AND I 100% SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK. PASTOR MIKE
ROGERS BAPTIST PASTOR IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND POP OFF
TO TWELVE GRAND KIDS. AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND SO SHOULD
YOU. PASTOR BRENT SNOW FROM SAN
BENITO COUNTY I SUPPORT SB SIX
SEVENTY THREE. MY NAME'S JOHN
PARTISAN RESIDENT ALAMEDA
COUNTY FATHER FOR CHILDREN I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NAME'S
ALICIA PRESS SEATTLE RICHARDS
AND I AM A MEMBER OF THE
PLACERVILLE. NOT EL DORADO
COUNTY I AM A MOTHER OF ONE THE
GRANDMOTHER OF TWO BEAUTIFUL
CHILDREN. AND. TWENTY FOUR
GREAT NIECES AND NEPHEWS THAT
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA AND I WANT
THEIR FUTURE TO BE BRIGHT AND
BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU MA'AM DO
SUPPORT THE BILL. WHAT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. BRENDA WOULD
THE LIFE MINISTRIES IN
RIVERSIDE AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. HI MY NAME IS MARLOWE
TUCKER I'M THE CALIFORNIA STATE
DIRECTOR OF CONCERNED WOMEN FOR
AMERICA WE HAVE TWENTY THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL SENATE BILL SIX SEVEN
THREE. THANK. ALISON HAYDEN
SPECIAL ED TEACHER. CANDIDATES
FOR CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
FIFTEEN ALAMEDA COUNTY. I
SUPPORT SENATE BILL SIX SEVEN
THREE. MODEL DALLAS MY LITTLE
TOO AND I WILL GET THE FOR
SPECIAL- OUR KIDS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS I SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS HEAD OF THE WIND TUNNEL
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. LINDA
COHN PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
FORMER DEBATE COACH. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL I'M FROM
YORBA LINDA CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SENATOR. MY NAME IS
COURTNEY MAY DANIEL I AM A
PLASTER COUNTY MOTHER OF TWO
PUBLIC SCHOOL CHILDREN I AM
ALSO WITH ADVOCATES FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. RACHEL
CARTELS FROM ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA
THE MOTHER OF THREE FROM INFORM
PARENTS OF ROCK AND ANY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. BILL PETERSON
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. YES TOM
PASSER IN THREE KILLED A YOUNG
MAN FROM COACHELLA CALIFORNIA
HI A SUPPORT ISRAEL 100%
ANIMATION BEAUTIFULLY SPANISH
I'D SAY SEIZING ON THIS. MY
NAME'S HIPOLITO FOR NON THIS
SEMI RETIRED DEPUTY SHERIFF I
AM A CURRENT- TOOK SU SCHOOL
COUNSELOR- ALSO A PASTOR AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. BERMAN
CHARLES TO WHAT BILL FATHER
PASTOR SACRAMENTO VALLEY FAMILY
CHURCH AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. DENISE JONES FONTANA
CALIFORNIA SEVENTY NO COUNTY IN
A STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL. I'M IDEA MONTANA
I MOTHER OF TWO. AND KILLED THE
BOYS AND I SUPPORT DISAPPEAR.
MY NAME IS SALLY WOULD I AM A
CONSTITUENT AND SENATOR GLAZERS
DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. I'M JENNIFER CHáVEZ
FROM FONTANA CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS MEAN THAT ABOUT ABOUT
AYE LOW. PLEASE GOES BEFORE THE
SENATE THEN HIGH SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK. MY NAME IS BY THE
SEATTLE OKAY ARE. GOOD ME SEE
HOLD NOT THEY MAY PASS YOUNG
WAS CUT THE MISSILE THE USABLE
GENERALLY. MY NAME IS DENNIS
MCCORD I'M A CHRISTIAN
EVANGELISTS THE GOSPEL OF JESUS
CHRIST WHO DIED FOR OUR SINS
AND ROSE FROM THE DEAD AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX SEVENTY
THREE. AND INDEED A RAKES CREST
AROUND MAKE. A CHRISTIAN AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL I AM SO
TEACHER. LARISSA AND RE GUYS
FOR COMMUNITY CHRISTIAN
FELLOWSHIP AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. FOR CHELLE
CONNOR PRESIDENT FREDERICK
DOUGLASS FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA MEMBER PAID
FELLOWSHIP TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS
WE SUPPORT SB SIX SEVENTY THREE.
MY NAME IS DAVID FISHER PRICE
FOLLOWER FROM CASTRO VALLEY AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SPREAD MCMILLAN FATHER OF THREE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. PAUL GALLO
FROM IN A ROCK FOR CALIFORNIA
IN A MEMBER OF INFORM PARENTS
AND I HAVE ELEVEN GRAND
CHILDREN AND YOU MUST SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. JOSEPH
DAY. FATHER TO A SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD GIRL. ON BEHALF OF FATHERS
EVERYWHERE I IMPLORE YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR MARIA MALLOW TELL I'M
FROM PACIFICA CALIFORNIA AND- A
MOTHER OF TWO BEAUTIFUL
DAUGHTERS AND REPRESENT THE SAN
FRANCISCO ARCHDIOCESE OF SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE SUPPORT AND I
STRONGLY STRONGLY IN
ABSOLUTELY- SUPPORT SB SEVEN
THREE THANK YOU HAVE A- THANK
YOU MA'AM ALL KQ THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FRIEDRICHS A VETERAN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER FORMER UNION
REPRESENTATIVE IN SAVANNAH
DISTRICT TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
FOUNDER OF FOR KIDS IN COUNTRY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I AM CHECK TO DECK
ELEVEN- CURSED DISTRICT EIGHT I
AM THE AFFILIATE LEADER OF THE
SALT AND LIGHT CHRISTIAN
MINISTRY OF FOR THE THREE
CATHOLIC CHURCHES IN MY AREA
AND ON BEHALF OF THE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO FAMILIES WE
SUPPORT SB SIX SEVEN THREE. MY
NAME'S MELINDA YOUNG AND I'M
WITH ALL MY MINISTRY DISTRICT
TO AND I'M IN FAVOR OF SB SIX
SEVEN THREE. DENISE OR JANA AND
I AM A MOTHER. EVEN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY NOW ALSO
PASTOR THERE I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. HEATHER OBERNOLTE CITY OF
BIG BEAR LAKE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. GAIL HUNT SAID
RESIDENT OF LAKE ARROWHEAD
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. VALERIE JACKSON A
MOTHER GRANDMOTHER AND OF
DIRECTOR FOR THE UNITED STATES
NATIONAL PER COUNCIL AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
THANK YOU FOR WAKING UP THE
CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY. YES. I AM
SO I CAN REPRESENT A TV NEXT
TRADITION OF I FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION REPRESENTING ALL
CC CURRY AND ASIAN CHURCHES
ACROSS AMERICA- CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY AND STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SIX SEVEN THREE THANK YOU.
UNLIKE MERRY CANDIDATE FOR
SUPERVISOR IN PLASTER COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MY NAME IS MADDIE ALIEN
ALLOW DEALS GRANDMOTHER- EIGHTY
CHILDREN AND I SUPPORT IS THERE.
TO WE'LL SEE IF WE GET T A
FRIEND AND I IMPAIR VALLEY THE
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. I CATHOLIC
WORSHIP SINGER. AND NOW TWO
GRANDCHILDREN SATTAR STRONGLY
SUPPORT DISK THIS BILL. MY NAME
IS MARK THEM ONTO A YEP AMONG
BROWN MY MOTHER IN I BELIEVE
JESUS IS THE ONLY WAY. TO
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS KAREN
GREEN PARIAHS I'M AT A HERE IN
SACRAMENTO RESIDENTS OF
SACRAMENTO A TEACHER FOR THE
LAST EIGHT AND A HALF YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE
REPRESENTING TRADITIONAL VALUES
OF NEXT GENERATION I DO A LOT
OF CHILDREN'S TEACHING AND
MINISTRY AND I SUPPORT SB SIX
SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU. SENATE
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA. A MOTHER
OF TWO CHRISTIAN AND WE HAVE
NOTHING TO HIDE IN HIDE NOTHING.
HI MY NAME S ME YOU CONNIE AND
I'M AS THE- JESUS CHRIST
FOLLOWER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. HELLO MY NAME IS
JESSICA ROMO I'M A MOTHER OF
FIVE I'M ALSO PART OF INFORM
PARENTS OF PLASTER COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. HEY FROM ELK
GROVE CALIFORNIA MOUNT MOM
GRANDMOTHER WIFE PASTOR PART
TIME HERE IT'S- CATER FOR
SPECIAL NEEDS AND I'M THINKING
GOD IN ADVANCE FOR PASSING THIS
BILL. MANAGE THE SEMEN MOTHER
OF TWO I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS HELEN BOND AND
FROM HERE CALIFORNIA I'M A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS JIM
TONIGHT TO A TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD COLLEGE STUDENT FROM SHOVEL
COLLEGE I'M REPRESENTING THE
COLLISION ASSOCIATION FOR THE
RESEARCH OF PRINCIPLES FROM THE
FEDERATION. AND I'M ALSO A SIGN
OF LOVING PARENTS AND SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS THE
BECAUSE THE MORE TIME A FATHER
AND THE US IS SOME POSSIBLE TO
FROM. ON. BETTER FAMILY CHURCH
SUPPORTING THIS BILL GET. MY
NAME IS YOUNG TWO ZERO MOTHER
OF TWO KEYS I AM CHRISTIAN ALL
REMINDED OF KOREAN CHURCH IN
SAN JOSE I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
TWO. SIX SEVEN THREE. MY NAME
IS THE HANNAH KONG I DO IMPAIR
LIKE TOLL ANA I HAVE LOST THREE
KIDS I AM STRONGLY SUPPORTS
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS TERRIBLY
I'M A MEMBER OF THE GROUP SO
THE KOREAN AMONG THE CHURCHES
SAN JOSE I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THIS BILL. I HAVE A FIVE KIDS
INSIDE A I'VE SUPPORTED THIS
BILL THANK YOU. HI I'M DEBBIE
KOBE SEARCH I HAVE FOUR KIDS
AND SIX GRANDCHILDREN AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE AND FOR PARENTS
OF EL DORADO COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. HI MY NAME
IS AMY SELLERS ON THE MOTHER OF
TEN AND FOR GRANDMOTHER OF
FIFTEEN. IN EL DORADO COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY
NAME IS SIMILAR RHONDA LIKE
COMING FROM THE BEES THEY
SUPPORT THE. MAY SHINING
CALIBRATION FOR CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL FOR SENATORS
THANK YOU FOR ANOTHER
LEGISLATIVE SESSION PRAYING-
BLESSINGS ON YOU THIS YEAR AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE
ON SB SIX SEVENTY THREE. HELLO
MY NAME IS PEGGY DELGADO FATHER
I AM A EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
BRIDGE NETWORK A LOCAL
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORTS
YOUTH AT RISK. PERSONALLY
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED A CHILDREN
AND TEENS AND THE YOUTH
ADVOCATE I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS SB SIX SEVEN THREE- TO-
GIVE PARENTAL RIGHTS AND
GUARDIANS MORE. CONTROL OVER
THEIR CHILDREN'S LIVES THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS MERRY SERI I'M
A MOTHER GRANDMOTHER GREAT
GRANDMOTHER I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS ALEX YOU
REPRESENTING CREON ACOSTA
BROADCASTING IN ANAHEIM
CALIFORNIA I'M THE ONE WHO
PERSONALLY DELIVER SEVEN
THOUSAND SUPPORT LETTER FROM
OUR LISTENERS YESTERDAY WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WHEN HE SAID
MY NAME TAKE LONG- FODDER TO
FROM CEREMONY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I'M JONI
MORRELL I AM THE PROUD
GRANDMOTHER IN CONCERN
GRANDMOTHER OF SEVEN. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I'M ALSO THE WIFE OF THE
SENATOR. FIVE MY NAME IS ERIC
REGARD RUNNING FOR ASSEMBLY
HERE IN THE KNIFE DISTRICT I'M
ALSO- HEAD OF THE PUBLIC
AWARENESS MINISTRY CALVARY
CHRISTIAN CENTER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
JAMIE HOW IN I AM A NURSE AT
DIRECTIONS MEDICAL CLINIC A
CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTER IN LODI
CALIFORNIA. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NAME IS
JACKIE CODA I AM WIFE OF A
DEPUTY SHERIFF JOHN CODA IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. RESIDENT OF
LIVERMORE TO CHILDREN AND-
PRESIDENT OF TRI VALLEY
REPUBLICANS AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I IN THE IN BIRD NINE I
AM A- MOTHER OF SIX.
GRANDMOTHER. I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. MY NAME IS PAT
TOMORROW AND I AM A MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'M BILL BECHTEL EVERY TEACHER
IN SAN LEANDRO SAN LORENZO HAVE
FATHER OF ONE AND GRANDFATHER
OF TWO SONS I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. MY NAME IS YOUNG
DEPEND TASK IT I AM A MOTHER OF
TWO CHILDREN IN PUBLIC SCHOOL
AND- TEACHER IN SANTA CLARA
SCHOOL ACCOUNT. SCHOOL DISTRICT
I STILL STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. DOUG SO LEASE BACK OF
BILL FOR A FATHER OF FOUR.
GRANDFATHER THREE AND I SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF LIBERTY CHURCH IN
FAIRFIELD- ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TIMOTHY C<c.cyan> CO FOUNDER OF</c>
TRADITIONAL VALUES FOR NEXT
GENERATION I'M MORE TO PASTOR I
STILL NEED SUPPORT THIS BILL. I
MEAN IT'S GREAT BURKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS. HI I AM
JULIE TORY A MOTHER OF TWO
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS MY GIRLS ARE IN
INCREASE IN PRIVATE SCHOOL BUT
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. I MANDIRI HAD STROM
I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SUPPORT THIS
BILLSB. SIX SEVEN THREE AND TO
NO I DON'T WANT A FLU SHOT. AND
GET THE EDGE FROM OCCURS
CALIFORNIA I DO NOT HAVE ANY OF
MY OWN CHILDREN OR
GRANDCHILDREN BUT THIS IS FOR
THE LITTLE ONES AND I REALLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU TO
EVAN THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BY SIR. IN THE NUMBER
OF MICE HAS A RIGHT TO SLEEP
BUT THE ORDER AND LET'S SEE THE
PHONE SOMEBODY IN CALIFORNIA E.
UP FOR YOU LES LES CAYES M. OF
ANY LOW ARE GIVE TO THE FOUR
FOUR LEVEL THAN ACROSS. THANK
YOU SIR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OKAY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IF YOU COULD COME
FORWARD AND IF YOU MAKE SOME
ROOM FOR THEM THAT WOULD BE
GREAT. LISTEN TO WHAT THEY SAY
SO COUNTY. BACK IN EVERY ARE
READY FOR THESE GUYS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- TWO SPEAKERS TWO
MINUTES EACH I WILL LET YOU
DECIDE WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST.
TAKE NOTES HAVE ANY. THANK
WHERE. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
WE'RE HERE TODAY AS A FORMER CO
SPONSOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY YOU SACKED AND
INSTRUCTORS ISSHIN IT TO SB SIX
SEVENTY THREE UNDERMINE
STANDARDS LAID OUT IN CHINA TO
PROTECT AND SAFETY OF OUR YOUTH
AND THOSE STANDARDS ARE WORKING
AS IT OUT AND ANALYSIS BIRTH
RATES AMONG TEENAGERS HAVE BEEN
DROPPING SINCE STATE AND TING
POLICY AROUND AND SAID SEXUAL
EDUCATION. AND NOTHING IN CHOI
IT REMOVES PARENTS FROM THE
EQUATION UNDER CURRENT LAW HAVE
THE FULL STORY UP THEIR
CHILDREN OUT OF THIS
INSTRUCTION AND IN STANDARD
PROPOSED WOULD CREATE A BIT
HERE THAT WOULD RESULT IN STATE
BEING ON. INTENTIONALLY PULLED
FROM. AND IT WOULD DENY MANY
STUDENTS. IN THOSE WHO ARE LOW.
MùT OR WHO WERE LIVING
HOMELESS. FOSTER CARE THAT
PUBLIC EDUCATION THAT THEY
DESERVE BECAUSE OF OTHER
PARENTS ABUSE. PARENTS HAVE THE
LEGAL RIGHT UNDER TRY OF COURSE
TO OPT THEIR CHILDREN OUT BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
OPT OTHER PEOPLE'S CHILDREN OUT
OF THAT EDUCATION. SO THIS BILL
WOULD NEGATIVELY AFFECT ALL
GROUPS THAT EXPERIENCE HEALTH
IS NOT JUST LGBT Q. PEOPLE BUT
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS WELL SO
FOR THOSE REASONS I MUST.
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
TODAY AND URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
DO THE SAME. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. HI HI MY NAME
IS MARYLAND CATCHER. IN I AM A
FILIPINA IMMIGRANT FOR WHOM
ENGLISH IS A SECOND LANGUAGE
I'M A PUBLIC EDUCATION PRODUCT.
I GRADUATED FROMTHE JESUIT
UNIVERSITY OF SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY. I AM A FORMER
SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER AND
I'M A CURRENT SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER. I AM HERE REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA A
SECULAR AND NON PARTISAN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION. THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS. WE HAVE TAKEN AN
OPPOSE SESSION ON THE BILL AT.
SEVENTY THREE THIS BILLS THIS
BILL SEEKS TO PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND PARENT ACCESS
TO SEXUAL HEALTH AND HIV
PREVENTION AND GRADES T. K.
THROUGH SIX. THOUGH THIS BILL
HAS SOME QUALITIES WE ARE IN
FAVOR OF LIKE TRANSPARENCY IN
THE ONLINE ACCESS TO THE
SCIENCE BASE MEDICALLY
APPROPRIATE. AND BELLA MENTALLY
APART CURRICULA THE INCLUSION
OF THE ACTIVE OFTEN IS OUR
PRIMARY REASON FOR OUR
OPPOSITION. SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN NATIONAL PTA IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA WHICH
HAS OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS. OF ALL ETHNICITIES
RELIGIONS FROM NORTHERN TELL
SOUTHERN FORMULA. WE HAVE
WORKED WITH THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO FAMILIES ON AIDS
AND HIV. THAT IS MEDICALLY
ACCURATE AND AGE APPROPRIATE WE
AFFIRM THIS IN A RESOLUTION HIV
S. T. D. PREVENTION EDUCATE OUR
SCHOOLS. FURTHER WE
SPECIFICALLY STATE P. A.
SUPPORTS THE RIGHT OF A PARENT
TO BE NOTIFIED ABOUT ANY COURSE
OF STUDY REGARDING SEX
EDUCATION AND TO REVIEW THE
CURRICULUM MATERIALS TO BE
USED. T. A FURTHER SUPPORTS THE
RIGHT OF A PARENT OR GUARDIAN
TO REQUEST IN WRITING THAT HIS
OR HER STUDENT BE EXCUSED FROM
SUCH A COURSE OF STUDY. IN OUR
POSITION STATE HEALTH EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA STATE TA THANK
SENATOR MORALE TO WORK TO MAKE
THE SEXUAL HEALTH AND HIV
PREVENTION TRANSPARENT AND
ACCESSIBLE TO PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS. SHOULD THE ACTIVE
OPT IN PROVISION BE WITHDRAWN
WE WOULD RECONSIDER OUR
POSITION AS WE WANT THE
GREATEST ACCESS FOR THE MOST
STUDENTS IN THIS AREA. I SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND PTA MEMBERS.
WE HAVE THIRTY SECONDS LEFT OF
THE FOUR MINUTES SO GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NOT A
PARENT WITH TWO CHILDREN ORANGE
COUNTY- I AM HERE TO ASK THAT
YOU RESPECTFULLY VOTE NO ON SB
SIX SEVENTY THREE- IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY I SUPPORT KEEPING THE-
OUTLOOK. WHICH IS THE BEST WAY
TO ENSURE THE GREATEST NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE INCLUDED.
WHILE STILL. IRVING THE RIGHTS
OF PARENTS TO EDUCATE THEIR
CHURCH ACCORDING TO THEIR
INDIVIDUAL BELIEFS AND VALUES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION NAME ORGANIZATION
AND THAT YOU OPPOSE THE BILL. I
ENGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU ALICE KESSLER BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA
ALSO A PARENT OF A PUBLIC
SCHOOL STUDENTS SECOND GRADE WE
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION WHICH IS
ALSO ONE OF THE LEADERS AGAINST
THE SKYROCKETING STD EPIDEMIC
IN OUR STATE ESPECIALLY. AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RON ROUTE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS. AS SENATOR MORALE
STATED WE ARE INDEED OPPOSED TO
SB SIX SEVEN THREE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SMALLER UPSET WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE OPPOSED. T.
PEREIRA- I WENT TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL IN BOTH FREMONT AN
ORANGE COUNTY- AND I AM A
SURVIVOR OF PREACH ISAAC SAID
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS CLAUDIA BOTTOM A SAN
FRANCISCO RESIDENT TWO TIME
EMMY AWARD AND PEABODY AWARD
WINNING JOURNALIST. STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL SEX EDUCATION
AND SEX SHOULD NOT BE FEARED OR
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF. ON BEHALF
OF OCT FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SAN
MIGUEL PROVIDING A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE YOU COULDN'T
BE HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL AND ALSO PERSONALLY AS
A STUDENT OF AGE APPROPRIATE.
SEX SAID IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
IN A PUBLIC SCHOOL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M CATHY. BUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA AND WE ARE
AND ON OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THANK. CHEN AND JAGGER
CALIFORNIA PTA WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING DIANE VELASCO HIGHLAND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OKAY WE WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DOES
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
SENATOR CHIANG. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I AM CHAIR. ARM OR WE
ALLOWED TO BRING BACK A CENTER
MORALS WITNESS ATTORNEY DEAN
FOR YOU YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY.
OKAY. YOUR SO MR BROYLES CAN
YOU PLEASE RESPOND TO THE
RESEARCH CITED BY THE ACLU THAT
APPEAR TO SHOW THAT AN OPT OUT
APPROACH IS MORE LINED UP WITH
THE INTENTIONS OF PARENTS AS
COMPARED TO AN OPT IN. ON.
THREE SEVEN ON. YEAH IT IS A
TESTIFIED EARLIER- BRIEFLY- THE
RAND RESEARCH STUDY IS WHAT'S
RELIED ON NOT ON ONLY BY THE
ACLU BUT IT'S REPEATED BY 80%
OF THE OPPOSITION LETTERS.
CITED AS A TO SUCH A DECISIVE
UP POINT THAT PARENTS PREFER
OPT OPT. OUT RATHER THAN OPT
IN. ABOUT FOUR AND FORTUNATELY
THE RAIN RESEARCH IS NOT
SUPPORT THE POSITION. THAT OPT
OUT PASSIVE CONSENT MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECTS PARENTS'
WISHES REGARDING COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUALITY EDUCATION. I'VE GOT A
COPY THE RAND STUDY HERE IN AND
ACTUALLY WAS- LIMITED STUDY OF
TWO SCHOOLS- END OF SEVENTH
GRADE CLASSES IN TWO SCHOOLS.
INITIALLY THERE WAS NOT
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUALITY
EDUCATION IT WAS STUDIED IN
FACT IT WAS- A DREAD
REHABILITATION AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM. AND PARENTS WERE
ACTUALLY NOT QUERIED AS TO WHAT
THEIR PURPOSE WAS AS FAR AS AN
OPT IN OR OPT OUT. OF THE ROOM
THE RAND RESEARCH TEAM- DEDUCED
FROM THE RESPONSE RATES FROM AN
OPT OUT IN ONE SCHOOL IN AN OPT
IN IN A SCHOOL WHAT'S PARENTS
WISHES WERE BUT THEY DIDN'T
ACTUALLY QUERY THE PARENTS ON
WHAT THEIR PREFERENCE WAS. IT
BUT EVEN IF THEY HAD. IS A
THIRTY ONE YEAR OLD STUDY IT
WAS A LIMITED POOL. OF SCHOOLS
AND WASN'T TALKING ABOUT
COMPREHENSIVE SEXUALITY
EDUCATION WHETHER PARENTS
PREFERRED AN OPT IN OR OPT OUT
ESPECIALLY. FOR YOUNGER
CHILDREN. AND SO THE STUDY
ITSELF IS. IT IT IT'S NOT EVEN
A STUDY OF OPT IN OPT OUT IN
THE SEXUALITY EDUCATION A
SPHERE NOR IS IT A STUDY-
INVOLVING AND HER CHILDREN. AND
SO THIS EVEN LOOK AT THE STUDY
YOURSELF I ENCOURAGE THE
SENATORS TO DO SO AND I'VE GOT
A COPY THE CITY HERE IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO SEE IT- BUT THEY
SPECULATED ABOUT WHAT PARENTAL
RIGHTS. WHAT PRINT PRINT
PARENTS PREFERRED AS FAR AS AN
OPT IN OR OPT OUT. BUT A COUPLE
POINT SOMEONE A QUOTE FROM THE
STUDY ITSELF. THERE THERE THERE
WAS TWO TWO POINTS ON PAGE FOR
THE STUDY VOTE. THIS EXTREMELY
SMALL POOL IS NOT GENERALIZE
GENERALIZABLE TO ALL SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS SHE CAN'T TAKE
THAT ONE STUDY THAT HAD DIDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING DO WITH SIX SAID
AND SAY WHAT AT APPLIES TO ANY
OTHER SCHOOL LET ALONE
REGARDING SEXUALITY EDUCATION
SECONDLY THE SITE THE RAND
STUDY SAYS QUOTE. DECIDING
WHETHER PASSIVE OR ACTIVE
CONSENT IS APPROPRIATE MUST BE
DECIDED ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
AND THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE TODAY IS TO
SAY YOU KNOW AN OPT OUT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE FOR SEVENTH THROUGH
TWELFTH GRADERS BUT AN OPT IN
WITH MORE PARENTAL BUT IN
CONTROL IS THE PRO. FOR YOUR
STUDENTS AND FINALLY WHAT I.
USE AN OPT IN OR OUT OPT OUT
APPROACH THE KEY ISSUE IS
INFORMED CONSENT. THE PARENTS
THEMSELVES ACTUALLY NEED TO BE
INFORMED OF WHAT THEY'RE BEING
ASKED TO DECIDE UPON IN OTHER
WORDS HAVE TO HAVE ACCESS
ACCESS TO THE CREEK ON
TRANSPARENCY IS THE KEY ISSUE
OF THIS BILL BUT SECONDLY- THEY
NEED TO- ACTUALLY HAVE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THEM. AND THE BEST
WAY TO FORCE PICKED HER PARENTS
TO GIVE ACTIVE CONSENT INFORMED
CONSENT IS ACTUALLY REQUIRE
THAT. URGE THE PARENTS TO LOOK
AT THE MATERIALS AND THAT'S
WHAT AN OP PRECISELY WITHIN
OFTEN DOES. NOT BEEN SAYS HEY
YOU'RE YOU'RE ACTIVELY.
DECIDING PROACTIVELY TO. PUT
YOUR CHILD IN THIS PROGRAM EVEN
THOUGH THEY MAY BE IS JOHN IS
FIVE YEARS OLD- THE AGE GROUP
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IS NOT
YOUNG ADULTS ARE LITTLE LITTLE
ADULTS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIVE
YEAR OLD CHILDREN- TO TWELVE
YEAR OLD CHILDREN. AND SO IF
YOU WANT TO HAVE ACTUAL
INFORMED CONSENT. WE NEED TO
HAVE AN OPT IN AND WE NEED THE
TRANSPARENCY INVOLVED.
OTHERWISE THERE'S A VERY BIG
DANGER THAT CHILDREN WILL BE
SUBJECTED TO EARLY SEXUALITY
EDUCATION WHEN THEIR PARENTS
ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
PROGRAM OR DON'T DON'T AT
CONSENT TO THEIR INVOLVEMENT.
SENATE CHANGE OF ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU KNOW I AM
JUST A MINUTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I AM A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL AND
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
POINTS MADE BY THE OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I TRULY SEE
THIS AS A PARENTAL RIGHTS ISSUE
AND A- A TRANSPARENCY ISSUE AND
I WILL ALWAYS SIDE WITH
PARENTAL RIGHTS AND
TRANSPARENCY. THANK YOU SO I'LL
BE VOTING AYE ON THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR WILL
YOU HAVE A QUESTION. YEAH I
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS FIRST
WAS FOR. MISS SMART WITH A
QUALITY CALIFORNIA. FIRST I
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE
TESTIMONY EVERYBODY COMING
TODAY YOU ARE VERY WELL BEHAVED
SO I SALUTE YOU FOR THAT- SO.
PTA SO THAT THEY'RE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. BUT THEY DO SUPPORT
THE TRANSPARENCY PORTION AS
RELATES TO POSTING ON THE
WEBSITE I WAS CURIOUS IF YOUR
ORGANIZATION SHARES THAT VIEW.
A SO IT'S OUR POSITION THAT THE
INSPECTION AND TRANSPARENCY
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA THESE ACTOR ALREADY
ROBUST- AND THAT CURRENT LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES FOR THAT
INSPECTION SO. I THINK WE VERY
A LITTLE BIT ON THAT POINT OKAY
THANK YOU SO DOT TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL SOSHE JUST SAID
THAT THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
YOUTH ACT HOUSE APPROPRIATE
CARS FOR PARENTAL RIGHTS CAN
YOU EXPLAIN TO ME HOW THIS
BILL. MAKES IMPROVEMENTS TO
THAT. THAT IS SIMPLY
CATEGORICALLY NOT TRUE THE ACT
ITSELF IS VERY VAGUE AS FAR AS
HOW PARENTS ARE GOING TO BE
INFORMED ABOUT- THE SEXUALITY
EDUCATION AT THEIR SEVENTY
TWELFTH GRADERS ARE GOING TO
RECEIVE AN OLDER GRADES AND
LIKE I SAID IN AN- CENTER
MORALES RECEIVED THOUSANDS OF
LETTERS. MY OFFICE HAS RECEIVED
HUNDREDS OF COMPLAINTS FROM
PARENTS ALL OVER THE STATE. WHO
HAD THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. GIVE
BRAG GIVE BARRIERS AND SO IT IT
SURPRISES ME THAT ORGANIZATION
CALLED THE PARENT TEACHER
ASSOCIATION WOULD ACTUALLY-
DISFAVOR PARENTS DID TO THE
THEY'RE THE ONES. THIS THIS
CURRICULUM IS ACTUALLY BEING
HIDDEN FROM PARENTS AND
CONCEALED FROM PARENTS FUND FOR
A MAKES INFORMED CONSENT
IMPOSSIBLE THIS IS BILL AND IT
IMPROVE IT. WELL IT AS AS AS I
STATED EARLIER IT'S IT MAKES US
GO TO SIX PUT ALL THE MATERIALS
ON THE WEBSITE. IN IN IN
LANGUAGES THAT IMMIGRANTS WILL
UNDERSTAND AND IN ENGLISH AND
OTHER LANGUAGES THAT ARE APPLE
ON IN EACH DISTRICT. SECONDLY
IT REQUIRES AN OPT IN SO IT
RATHER THAN PARENTS JUST
IGNORING A NOTICE AND NOT
SIGNING THEIR PARENTS OUT OF
THE PROGRAM IT REQUIRES PARENTS
ACTUALLY DECIDE PROACTIVELY
THAT THEIR CHILD IS THAT THE
MATERIAL IS AGE APPROPRIATE
MEDICALLY ACCURATE ENOUGH FOR
THEIR CHILD. AND SO IT'S AN
ACTIVE CONSENT- IT'S AN
INFORMED CONSENT AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
OLDER GRADES IS NOT INFORMED
CONSENT IT'S CONCEALED- IT'S
ACTUALLY. A LOT OF THE
HAPPENINGS ACTUALLY DECEPTIVE
AND GREAT WHITE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WANT TO MOVE
THE BILL. HAVING SAID THAT I
WHAT I SEE A LOT OF NEW FACES
HERE TODAY I'M GLAD YOU'RE HERE
YOU NEED TO STAY ENGAGED. IF
YOU'RE NOT SURE WHAT'S GOING ON
IN THIS BUILDING. WE ARE HAVING
OUR OWN PRIVATE VERSION AT
ANIMAL FARM POLICY MAKERS. IN
THIS BUILDING WANT TO RAISE
YOUR CHILDREN WHEN IT COMES TO
A CHOI AT SCHOOL CHOICE COMES
TO HAVING INPUT ON CURRICULUM-
WE WERE PUT GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRATS IN BETWEEN DOCTORS
AND PARENTS AND CHILDREN ALL
THESE THINGS ARE GOING ON. AND
SO I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY YOU HAVE TO STAY ENGAGED
OR YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE CONTROL
OF THE BILL WOULD BE TO RAISE
YOUR OWN CHILDREN CAN I JUST
ADD SOMETHING QUICKLY DON'T
KNOW. YOU MAY NOT. OKAY ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PAN.
THANK YOU EXCERPTED MENU WHICH
NAME AGAIN SIR SAREEN BROYLES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
PRESS AYE- APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY UP BUT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION AND MAYBE THERE'S A
QUESTION STAFF CAN HELP WITH-
THIS ROSE CONCERT REFER TO
SEXUALITY EDUCATION I AM NOT
SURE I SEE THAT IN THE CODE
THAT WE HAVE SEXUALITY
EDUCATION I BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS EDUCATION STANDARDS AROUND-
SEXUAL HEALTH H. I. MENTIONED
BUT I HAVE NOT SEEN. YEAH HI
I'M JUST I JUST BE CLEAR. SO
YOU ARE CORRECT IS ABOUT SEX
EDUCATION OKAY HEALTH EDUCATE-
WELL MAYBE A SUBTLE DISTINCTION
I THINK LET'S LET'S I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT ONE SO I HOPE
THAT WE CAN MORE ACTUALLY
REPRESENT WHAT THE CODE
ACTUALLY SAYS- THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE IS THAT-
CERTAINLY- SO MORALE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND THE I. BUT
AND I'VE WELCOME IN FACT- THE
PTA SO ALSO STAND SUPPORT OF-
BE SURE THAT WE HAVE-
TRANSPARENCY ON THE CURRICULUM
MATERIALS- BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT THE WITNESS IS PRO
ACTUALLY SAID PART OF THE
PURPOSES BILLS TO FORCE PARENTS.
AND YET THIS IS BEING FRAMED AS
A PARENTAL RIGHTS- BUT YET THE
TESTIMONY WAS ABOUT FORCING
PARENTS. SO I'M A LITTLE
DISTURBED ABOUT THAT AS WELL-
AND- YEAH AGAIN I THINK
CERTAINLY PARENTS SHOULD HAVE
THE ABILITY TO. REVIEW THE
CURRICULA AND CHOOSE TO OPT HER
CHILD OUT. THEIR OWN CHILDREN
BUT AGAIN. YOU KNOW THIS IS
PART OF THE CURRICULUM AND I
GUESS THE OTHER AND IN FACT-
ANY SORT OF CURRICULA THAT'S
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT'S
NOT JUST THE STATE IT'S ALSO.
COUNTY AND WE HAVE SCHOOL
BOARDS THAT MAKE DECISIONS AS
WELL AND I BELIEVE THEY HAVE TO
REVIEW CURRICULA THAT'S BEING
TIGHTENED AS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE WAY AND WITH THE
PARTICULAR SCHOOL BOARD. I
WITHIN THE STATE STATE
STANDARDS. THERE IS ARE THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES ACTUALLY
NUMEROUS OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUBLIC VETTING OF- THE OF
STANDARDS BOTH NOW AT SEA LEVEL
BUT ALSO MORE SPECIFICALLY AT
THE SCHOOL BOARD LEVEL COULD
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT. AND
PERHAPS ALSO THAT HE- CAN I
COMMENT ON YOUR
CHARACTERIZATION OF MY
TESTIMONY BUT I AM JUST QUOTE
AT NO YOU'RE MISREPRESENTING
WHEN I SAID. I SAID THAT.
TRANSPARENCY AND- AND AN PT IN
IS MORE LIKELY TO MAKE MAKE
SURE THE PARENTS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE
CURRICULUM TO MAKE A DECISION.
MY IT IF I USE THE WORD FORCING
IT WAS IT WAS NOT I'M NOT
TRYING TO HOLD A GUN TO PARENTS
HEADS. I JUST THINK IT'S BETTER
TO HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND CHOICE
IN FULL DISCLOSURE FOR THE
PARENTS ACTUALLY MAKE THE
DECISION AND NOT THE STATE FOR
THEM. THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING.
WHO IS YOUR QUESTION. ACTUALLY
WAS FIRST- ASKING THE AUTHOR
AND THEN PERHAPS ALSO. THE PTA
PERHAPS ALSO COMMENT ON THE
LEVEL OF- REVIEWER FOR RENTAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTAL AND
PUT IN CURRICULA. GENERAL HELLO
AGAIN. BUT LET ME EXPLAIN THE
OPT OUT. THE OPT OUT. I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS CENTER PAN A
QUESTION MY QUESTION WAS THE
OPPORTUNITY DEPUTIES FOR
PARENTAL INPUT- POST AT THE
STATE LEVEL OF THE SCHOOL BOARD
LEVEL AND OF COURSE I THINK WE
ALL HOPEFULLY WE ALL AGREED
THAT- PARENTS THIS THING WHILE
ARE ALLOWED TO. OPT THEIR OWN
CHILDREN OUT. EXPLAINING IS.
WHAT A SO IT PEOPLE CAN MOVE
YOU CAN MISS THE MAIL THAT'S
WHY THE OPT IN YOU KNOW IT'S
PARENTAL PARTICIPATION BUT A
REVIEW THE MATERIAL AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO SIGN A PERMISSION
SLIP YOU DON'T NEED TO ROLL
YOUR EYES BY THE WAY BUT-
ANYWAY. SO AND MORALE. ISN'T
LOOKING AT YOU I WAS LOOKING AT
DOCTOR PAN PLEASE PROCEED. SO
ANYWAY THEY OFTEN THE OPT OUTS
PASSIVE THE OPT IN IS AN ACTIVE
ONE BECAUSE AGAIN WE WANT THE
PARENTS FEEL OF REVIEW THE
ENTIRE MATERIAL BUT WE WANT
PARENTS HAVE ACCESS WE WANT
PARENTS BE INVOLVED IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION SPECIAL
HANNAH SUBJECT CONSENT OF SAS
BECAUSE SOMETHING'S I THINK GET
MISCONSTRUED OUR FRIEND HERE
FROM THE OF WHAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT STUDY CHAU PREGNANCIES
DOWN THAT'S ATTACKER BUT WE'RE
ALL. OF FIRST SECOND YEARS
RIGHT YEAH YEAH THAT'S SO YOUNG
MAY BE STARTING A LITTLE BIT
LATER BUT BUT- AND- I THINK
THIS CENSUS. A SENSITIVE
MATERIAL WE WANT TO PAY. AND WE
THINK IT'S THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO THAT WEBSITE
AND THEN AT THAT POINT IN TIME
THEY CAN SIGN YOUR KID UP IF
THEY THINK THE DATA IS AGE
APPROPRIATE FORM. OKAY TWELVE
WHAT'S MORE OF AN ACTIVE THING
ON THE PARENTS PART. LOOK FOR
ACTION SORRY. OKAY THANK YOU
HAVE CENTER PAN WRAPS THE PTA
ALSO ANSWER THE QUESTION MORE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED WAS ABOUT
THE OPTIONS FOR PARENTAL INPUT.
AT BOTH THE SCHOOL BOARD AND
THE- STATE LEVEL PUT MORE
PERHAPS MORE SPECIFICALLY ON
SCHOOL BOARD LEVEL. THE. THANK
YOU. THE PTA VALUES- PARENT
PARENTAL ENGAGEMENT IN FACT WE
COSPONSORED A BILL ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO THAT CHANGED AT GO TO
MAKE SURE. THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ENCOURAGE AND-
FACILITATE PARENTS ENGAGEMENT
IN MAKING DECISIONS THAT'S PART
OF THE LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. SO WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT RENTAL OF FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES THERE AND THAT'S
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE WANT WE WANT
PARENTS AND FAMILIES TO FEEL.
LIKE THEY HAVE SOME VOICE IT
IS. IN THEIR COMMUNITY PTA
KNOWS THAT WE HAVE A
PLURALISTIC SO EIGHTY THAT
MEANS WE HAVE PEOPLE OF ALL
RELIGIONS WE HAVE PEOPLE OF ALL
ETHNICITIES. ALL POLICE SYSTEMS
CALIFORNIA PTA IS ALL CHILDREN
WE HAVE A GROUP. FOR PARENTS
AND FAMILIES TO ULTIMATELY HAVE
THAT HE'S AND IT IS A GLOBAL AT
THE SCHOOL. THANK YOU SIR NEED.
OKAY I HAVE I APPRECIATE TO AND
I SHARE YOUR DESIRE TO HAVE
MORE PARENTAL ENGAGEMENT- AND I
THINK AND YOU'RE RIGHT- FRONTAL
ENGAGEMENTS- USUALLY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH TEACHERS AND-
AGAIN ELECTED SCHOOL BOARDS-
HELP AND- FOR- PERFORMANCE OF
OUR OF STUDENTS OF PARTICULARLY
PARENTAL ENGAGEMENT OF THEIR
OWN CHILDREN YEAH AND THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING WE VALUE ON
WHICH TO HAPPEN- I THINK- YEAH
MIGHT IN TURN. THAT WHAT DO
HAVE MULTIPLE MECHANISMS FOR
PEOPLE TO BOTH BE ENGAGED IN
THE OVERALL DEVELOPMENT OF THE
CURRICULA. WE JUST HEARD.
CERTAINLY WE CREATE GIVE THE
OPPORTUNITY- FOR PARENTS FOR
THEIR OWN CHILDREN TO OPT OUT-
MY CONCERN IS THAT- BY CREATING
AN OPT IN WE'RE ACTUALLY
DENYING- SOME CHILDREN TO- MAY
NOT AND FORTUNATELY HAVE A
FAMILY SITUATION OR SOCIAL
SITUATION THAT MAKES IT- AS IS
POSSIBLE FOR THOSE FAMILIES TO
BE ABLE TO- TO BE ES DID TO
ACTUALLY MAY LOSE OUT ON AN FOR
IT POURTANT. THEIR EDUCATION
AND WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS
ACTUALLY HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY.
THE WAY AND THAT AND AGAIN I
WOULD FIND YOU THAT THE ACTION
I WAS TO SAY IS THAT THE
OVERALL CURRICULA IS SOMETHING
THAT DOES GO THROUGH A YOU KNOW
OF A PUBLIC PROCESS BOTH AT THE
STATE THE STANDS ARE SET STATE
AND ALSO THE SCHOOL BOARD LEVEL
SO. THAT MEANS THE COMMUNITY AT
LARGE THIS IS A STANDARD THAT
WE- THE WHOLE. AND CERTAINLY IF
PARENTS WISH THEIR CHILDREN OUT
OF CERTAIN PIECES OF THAT-
UNDERSTAND THAT- BUT I THINK
THAT IN THE ABSENCE OF AN
ACTIVE DECISION. TO OPT OUT
THAT SINCE WE'VE COMMUNITY
COLLECTIVELY OF SAID THIS IS
SOMETHING AS IMPORTANT PARTS ON
EDUCATION. THE CHAU CHILDREN
SHOULD BE A FAILED OF THAT
UNLESS. SAID THAT THIRTY DAY
FOR THEIR OWN CHILDREN I
DISAGREE SO- ITH THAT AND FOR
SHALL NOT ABLE TO SUPPORT BILL
TONIGHT. OUR FINAL QUESTION SO
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
YES. OKAY SO WHAT I SEE THE OP
ART. THE HOUSE AND THE PAIR MAY
NOT MAIL IT BACK SO THIS. THE
EDUCATION BUT WHAT IF THEY MOVE
WHAT IF THEY DON'T LOOK AT THE
MAIL- THAT IS GOING TO BE FEWER
PARTICIPANTS BUT THE OFTEN
AGAIN IS SOMETHING THAT EVERY
PARENT WILL HAVE TO. DECIDE TO
DO SO I'M I'M LOSING YOU A
LITTLE BIT DIRECT NATION SORT
OF CUTS BOTH WAYS NOW ALSO. BUT
THE FOR SEE DOCTOR AND- USUALLY
THE OTHERS SO I WOULD JUST SAY
IS THAT WE HAVE A PROCESS.
WHERE WE ENGAGED THE PUBLIC AND
PARENTS AND I. GUIDE SCHOOL
BOARD YOU SEE A LOT OF PARENTS
THERE- SHOW UP AND SO THE
SCHOOL BOARD. ESTABLISHES
CURRICULA OUT AT HAS TO PROVE
CURRICULA YOU'RE WORKING WITH
THE TEACHERS WE ARE AT THE
STATE WE HAVE A VERY PUBLIC
PROCESS AS PUBLIC NOTICE THE
ONLY OF NOTICES GO OUT CETERA.
AND SCHOOL BOARDS HAVE TO
REVIEW AND CURRICULA SO IN
PROCESS WHICH WE- DO THROUGH
THE MARKETS THE RIGHT. PART
NUMBER RIGHT WE- WE HAVE TO OUR
ELECTED TO LEGISLATURE LIKE YOU
AND I. DO AND WE HAVE. SO THOSE
ESTABLISH A SENSE LEADER AND
COMMUNITY STANDARDS FOR THAT.
BE DEFERRED OFTEN VERY MUCH TO
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS SO AGAIN
THERE'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
HERE AT STATE BUT MORE
SPECIFICALLY IN SCHOOL
ESTABLISH WHAT ARE THE
EDUCATIONAL. CURRICULA AND
STANDARDS WE WISH TO TEACH AND
A PARTICULAR SCHOOL DISTRICT
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A BIZARRE-
THROUGH THAT PROCESS WE
ESTABLISH A COMMUNITY STANDARD
PAT. THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
CURRICULUM- THIS THIS
PARTICULAR COMPONENT WE ALSO
PROVIDE. IF YOU CHOOSE TO SAY
WHY DON'T AGREE WITH THE
COMMUNITY AT LARGE. AND I DON'T
WANT MY CHILD THIS PARTICULAR
PORTION EDUCATION WE GIVE
PEOPLE THE OPRY THE OPT OUT BUT
SAYS THAT BECAUSE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS TO
PUBLISH THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD BE PART OF THE
STANDARD. CURRICULUM IN
EDUCATION. STUDENT IN THIS
PARTICULAR SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
IN THE STATE RIGHT AT THE WHAT
THE VAN THAT SHOULD BE THE
DEFAULT. RATE THAT IS WHAT YOU
SHOULD BE GET. UNLESS YOU SAY
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT I THE ONLY
BE AND I DON'T WANT MY CHILD
TAKE OF THIS PARTICULAR PORTION
OF THE EDUCATION. THAT IS
THAT'S AN OPT OUT. BLOOM IS
OTHER AROUND THE SAME THE EVEN
THOUGH WE AS A COMMUNITY FOR.
ALL THE REASONS THAT WE'VE
DECIDED THAT AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE STATION. ESTABLISHED
CREEK. THAT UNLESS YOU SEE THAT
IF YOU DO OPT IN THAT MEANS IN.
WHO AT SOME OF THE SET ISN'T
USED. OUT THE THING IN. LATE
WILL BE DENIED AN EDUCATION
THAT WE AS A COMMUNITY THINK
THAT EVERY CHILD. OUT YOU KNOW
OF COURSE RECOGNIZING THAT
PARENTS THEMSELVES CAN SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT MAYBE I DON'T WANT MY
CHILD TO GET THAT PART BECAUSE
I HAVE A DIFFERENT OPINION THAN
THE GENERAL UNITY. WE IN THE
OPPORTUNITY BUT IF WE DO. BUT
OTHERWISE I WOULD SAY IS THAT.
THE DEFAULT SHOULD BE THAT WE
WENT THROUGH. HELLO YES WE HAD
A LOT TO THE SCHOOL BOARD.
PROCESS TO ESTABLISH WHAT THE
CURRICULUM SHOULD BE THAT EVERY
CHILD GETS. SHOULD AT THE
PARENT HAS A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION DATE OF THE OPERATING
ROOM TROUT THAT. WITHOUT
ACTUALLY SAYING. MY CHECK NO
PORTION THE EDUCATION THAT IS.
LIKE THE GENERAL EDUCATION THEY
CAN ALSO GO ARGUE WITH SCHOOL
BOARD ABOUT WELL WE DON'T WANT
CHAGE THE CONTENT I'M NOT YOU
KNOW I HAVE A CONCERN THAT
OTHER CHILDREN HAVE ANY
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T AGREE
WITH. HELLO TALK TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD YOU HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION SCHOOL WHICH ALSO
BY THE WAY HAS ELECTED MEMBERS
ON THAT BOARD IBM THAT'S- LIKE
THE ICING. ON THAT BUT- THAT IS
MY POINT OF VIEW ABOUT HOW WE
SHOULD HEAR ABOUT YEAH THIS
PARTICULAR AND TO ANSWER THAT
THE REASON WE GOT THIS BILL
GONE IS THE OPT OUTREALLY CUTS
PARENTS OUT A LOOP IN MANY WAYS
BECAUSE HOW THIS GOT STARTED A
THE PASTOR IN MY DISTRICT
ACTUALLY CALLED ME AND TOLD ME
WHAT HE DID HE FOUND OUT HIS
DISTRICT. WHAT THE SCHOOL
IMPLEMENTED THIS TO CURRICULUM
OKAY. ANY BOARD APPROVAL. AND
WITHOUT ANY- TELL ANY PARENT SO
THE PARENTS WERE SHOCKED WHEN
THEIR KIDS CAME HOME TOLL THAT.
FULL IT TO HIM SO HE DID A
LITTLE RESEARCH HE HAS A LARGE
CONGREGATION. AND HE ASKS
CONGER GETS TO- TAKEN KEEP
THESE KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL FOR A
DAY AND THEY DID. AN ARE THE
SCHOOL SUPERINTENDENT WAS DOWN
THERE PRETTY QUICK I THINK
ASKING FOR FORGIVENESS OR
SOMETHING. BUT THE THING IS SEE
THIS HAPPENING OTHER PLACES TOO
SO THE OPT OUT IS NOT. WORKING
BECAUSE- IT'S ARE FINDING OUT
AFTER THE FACT THEIR KIDS GET
THIS. INFORMATION THEN THEY
FOUND OUT CUT OFF. SHOULD A
MALE THAT THING IN AS IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO TO HAVE THE PARENTS REVIEW
THE MATERIAL. MY GOODNESS AGAIN
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT I'VE BEEN
MENTION IS WHERE YOU GO FIELD
TRIP. YOU NEED A PERMISSION
SLIP AND SO ONCE. A AND AGAIN
IT'S GREATER ACCESS TO THE
PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO REVIEW
THAT STUFF AND THEY SHOULD HAVE
AN ACTIVE WAY OF SIGN YOUR
CHILD UP JUST LIKE THEY DO ON
FIELD TRIPS- YOU CAN HAVE A-
HIGHER PROPENSITY OF PARENTS.
MAKING A DECISION. WILL DOUBT
THAT SMASHED. YOU GET THIS SOON
WHICH- OR DO WHAT BILL TRAP
THAT WE MAIL A LETTER THE
PARENT TOLL ON. A FIELD TRIP
NOTHING COMES BACK THAT MUST BE
I MEAN. YOU COULD LOWER BELLY
CAN GO. PLAY WITH THE TIGERS
THAT VISIT. SO THANK YOU DOCTOR
PAN AT A PREVIOUS THAT I'LL
NOTE I AM A FATHER- USUALLY THE
PERMISSION SLIP FOR THE FIELD
TRIP IS ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY'RE TRAVELING OUT OF THE
SCHOOL AND WHAT THERE'S A
DESCRIPTION OF THE TURTLE
OCCASIONAL WHICH THEY'RE GOING-
OUTSIDE AND HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE ACTUAL CONTENT
USUALLY I HAVE TO CALL AND FIND
OUT TO THE PERMISSIONS REALLY
ABOUT REMOVAL THE CHILD FROM
THE SCHOOL THE REST OF OUR- TWO
OTHER ENVIRO. BUT I'M OKAY WITH
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE
FAULT. SO YOU KNOW I THINK
QUIBBLE ABOUT THAT. CAN I
EXPRESSED MY CONCERNS AND-
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE ADOPTING
FOR DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PANCER WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO I WENT
TO THE PARENTAL RIGHTS- MY A.
Y. SPENT- FIVE YEARS TEACHING
HIV AIDS THE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT WAS KIND OF
BURSTING SOMETIMES BE LIKE IN A
SUPERMARKET SOME GO HEY THERE'S
A SEX LADY. SO I WAS MARRIED TO
THE SEX LADY FOR ABOUT FIVE
YEARS WHICH HAS BEEN GREAT- SO
THE OPPONENTS TO THE BILL HAVE
TALKED ABOUT HOW WE HAVE ALL
THE SAFEGUARDS AND EVERYTHING'S
HUNKY DORY. ANY SENSE I DON'T
LAST BUT THE ONE THAT HAS
BROUGHT THIS PROPOSED SIZE EACH
COUPLE MAYES TED BRIEFLY SHARE
YOUR STORY BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT
DID NOT WORK YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
WORK FOR ME MY DISTRICT
IMPLEMENTED CURRICULUM WITHOUT
BOARD OVER SO. WHAT DISTRICT
WAS COUNTY LET'S DISTRICT THANK
YOU BELL SITE WITH REVIEW.
WITHOUT ABOARD VOTE AND NO
PARENT INPUT ELEVEN SINCE FOR
TEN YOUR. IN THE CURRICULUM ME
FOR ABOUT FOUR FIVE WEEKS WHEN
I CONFRONTED THE STAFFER. AND
ASKED HER IT APPEARS TO ME IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE TRYING TO.
STOP ME FROM SEEING THIS
CURRICULUM IS THAT JUST MY
IMPRESSION OR- IS WHAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO. AND SHE
ADMITTED THAT SHE DIDN'T WANT
ME TO SEE IT. AND THE REASON
WHY SHE DIDN'T IS BECAUSE EVERY
PARENT WHO. DID. UP THERE TOO
OUT. NOW WHEN I DO IT. I DID UP
TO MY CHILDREN OUT. AND BECAUSE
OF THAT ISSUE OF MY BOARD
IMPLEMENTING THIS CURRICULUM
AND HIDING IT FROM ME IT
MEETING THAT THEY DID SO AND
THE STAFF FOR EVEN ADMITTED IT
TO THE BOARD IN A BOARD. IN OF
THE HATTER COME A PRESENT TO
THE BOARD. AND SHE SHE THAT. MY
STE THREE HOWEVER IS NOT UNIQUE
TO MY DISTRICT. IT IS TOLD BY
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE'RE DISTRICTS ARE. REGULAR
DURING AN OPT OUT THE MANY MANY.
WHO HAVE HAD THEIR CHILDREN
OPTED OUT AND THEY WERE
INSTRUCTED ANYWAY SO THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH THE OPT OUT WE
NEED AN OPT IN TWO INCH- THAT
PARENTS HAVE MADE THE DECISION
AND THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL
COMPLY IT. IS INTO THAT I
INTENDED. SAID THAT IF SHE IS
AVAILABLE TO HER AND OPT IN FOR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL STUDENT SHE
WOULD HAVE DONE IT BUT THE LAW
PROHIBITED NOW WHY DID SHE WANT
THAT OFF AND SHE WANTED IT
BECAUSE SHE FELT THAT THE
SCHOOL THIS AND THE TEACHERS
BOARD WERE AT RISK THE BILL IF
THE ISSUE. AND YOU TO THOSE
LIABILITY SHE THE END UP AND
PROTECTED THEM. THAT'S MY
SUPERINTENDENT AND I WOULD JUST
SAY TO YOUR SUPERINTENDENT.
BELOW SEVENTH GRADERS SO K.
THROUGH SIX EVERY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN OUR DISTRICT IN THE
STATE HAS THE OPT IN RIGHT SO
THEY ALREADY HAVE THAT RIGHT
NOT ACCORDING TO HER YET
ACCORDING TO HER IT'S IN THE
EDUCATION CODE IF YOU READ IT
YOU WILL SEE IT. YOU KNOW WHAT.
TOLD YOU WHAT THE RULES WERE
WHEN WE STARTED IF YOU LIKE IT
YOU GO LIKE THIS IF YOU DON'T
LIKE IT YOUR QUIET OTHERWISE
YOU'LL BE ASKED TO LEAVE. THIS
BILL PLACES THE OPT IN IN THE
CODE. FOR ELEMENTARY K. THROUGH
SIX THE IT'S ALREADY THERE
SENATOR MORALE. OKAY ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS SENATOR DRAWS
SO. YES JUST THE LAST QUESTION
IF I COULD ASK THE OTHER TWO
WITNESSES TO COMMENT PLEASE.
HELP IS THERE A SPECIFIC
QUESTION THE LAST QUESTION
ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE- YES THANK
YOU HI MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MCKNIGHT I AM A PARENT
CAPISTRANO UNIFIED IN ORANGE
COUNTY- OUR DISTRICT WENT
THROUGH A VERY VERY- ROBUST
REVIEW PROCESS WE HAD A- SEX ED
TASK FORCE WHICH MANY DISTRICTS
ARE SAYING IN MY COUNTY. I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE AS ALWAYS I
WAS ALSO PART OF THAT TASK
FORCE AND WE HAD SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PARENTAL
INPUT AT BOARD MEETINGS. AS
WELL AS IN THE SEX A TASK FORCE.
OUR DISTRICT PRESENTED THE
CURRICULA AT SEVERAL DIFFERENT
MIDDLE SCHOOLS- OVER PROBABLY A
FOUR WEEK PERIOD THEY ALSO DID
Q. AND A SESSIONS THEY ALSO
ACCEPTED. RENTAL QUESTIONS TO
BE PUT ON A CARD SO. BY THE
TIME IN OUR BOARD DID VOTE ON
IT AND BY THE TIME WE ACTUALLY
DID HAVE A CURRICULA THAT WE
WERE SATISFIED WITH THERE WERE
SEVERAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARENTS TO HAVE INPUT IN THE
COMMUNITY- OUR DISTRICT ALSO
HAS TWO BINDERS ONE FOR MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND ONE FOR HIGH SCHOOL.
IN OUR DISTRICT OFFICE YOU ARE
ABLE TO GO IN THAT OFFICE
WHETHER OR NOT YOU ARE A PARENT
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE CURRICULA
YOU CAN READ IT. ALL THE VIDEOS
THAT ARE PART OF OUR SEX ED
CURRICULUM ARE LISTED THERE AS
WELL. THERE IS FULL
TRANSPARENCY WE HAVE PHONE
CALLS WE HAVE EMAILS- IT'S IN
THE PRINCIPLES LETTER IT'S
BASICALLY EVERYWHERE AND- EVEN
WITH THAT I WOULD SAY THERE
WERE STILL SOME. CONTROVERSY
AROUND BUT WE ACTUALLY DID COME
UP WITH- WE'VE IMPLEMENTED IT
IN THIS LAST YEAR THE FEEDBACK
FROM OUR SUPERINTENDENT OF
CURRICULUM. FROM OUR PRINCIPLES
AND FROM THE STUDENTS AN ADMIN
HAS BEEN VERY VERY POSITIVE WE
HAD VERY FEW PEOPLE OPTING OUT.
AND IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WE'RE COMING TOGETHER
AGAIN TO SORT OF REVIEW WHAT'S
MISSING WHAT CAN WE ADD WHAT
WAS NOT NECESSARY AGAIN WITH
PARENTAL INPUT. SO I HAD A VERY
POSITIVE XPERIENCE IN
CAPISTRANO YOU RIDE WITH OUR
TASK FORCE AND OUR OUR PROCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
RUSSELL. IT SEEMS TO ME THAT'S
PROBABLY THE- MODEL. THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LOCAL AGENCIES
SHOULD FOLLOW- I AM A 100% FOR
PARENT INVOLVEMENT FOR PARENT.
KNOWLEDGE OF FULL DISCLOSURE TO
PARENTS I COME FROM COMMUNITIES
THAT- MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES
THAT- HAVE TRADITIONALLY
HISTORICALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
THAT KIND OF DECISION MAKING
SOME VERY BIG. AND IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ME FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PARENTS TO BE
INVOLVED N THE DECISION MAKING
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT'S WHAT
WE OUGHT TO FIX. IF IT'S BEING
DONE THE WRONG WAY IF PARENTS
ARE NOT BEING INCLUDED IF
DISTRICTS ARE MAKING DECISIONS
WITH THAT. MOMENT THAT'S THE
PROBLEM THAT WE SHOULD ADDRESS
THAT'S A PROBLEM WE SHOULD FIX.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THAT BUT
I THINK THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO.
THE WAY THAT IT IS SET UP THERE
IS AN ITEM NOT GOING TO REPEAT
EVERYTHING THAT SENATOR POUND
SAID BUT THE WAY IT'S SET UP IS
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES. TO GO
pNOT LET'S FIX THAT UP THAT'S
THE PROCESS WERE PARENTS SHOULD
BE INVOLVED- I DO THINK THAT
THOSE THAT PROCESS SHOULD
INVOLVE OF AN OPPORTUNITY FOR-
NON ENGLISH SPEAKING OR NON
PRIMARY ENGLISH SPEAKING PEOPLE
AND COMMUNITIES TO BE INVOLVED
SO I WOULD. WISH FOR THAT UP
PART AS WELL. OF AND THEN LEAVE
IF YOU DON'T AGREE WITH THAT
DECISION YOU CAN HAVE YOUR
CHILD NOT PARTICIPATE SO I'VE
SEEN. WHAT I SEE BEFORE ME IS.
A WAY IN WHICH EVERY PARENT
EITHER COLLECTIVE OR
INDIVIDUALLY PERSONALLY THE
RIGHT. TO IS HAS A RIGHT TO
MAKE THAT DECISION ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN- AND I THINK THAT
THERE IT'S IMPORTANT. I SEE
THIS EDUCATION AS A HEALTH. A
HEALTH ISSUE UP IN. OUR PARK
BUILDER NEED TO BE TAUGHT AND
IF WE DON'T AGREE HOW LET'S
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THAT BUT
IT IS A HEALTH CARE ISSUE AND I
THINK THE ISSUE OF TEEN
PREGNANCIES IS JUST ONE PIECE
OF IT. THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS INVOLVED WITH SEX
EDUCATION THE IT'S NOT
SEXUALITY IT'S ABOUT THE HEALTH
CARE OF OUR CHILDREN SO I'M
REALLY GLAD TO HEAR THE MODEL.
THAT YOU MADE UP- AND- BECAUSE
I FEEL THAT THERE IS A PROCESS
FOR PARENTS TO BE INVOLVED TO
MAKE DECISIONS- THAT I WILL BE
OPPOSE IN THIS. THANK YOU
CENTER ALSO ANY FURTHER
COMMENTS OR DISCUSSION FROM THE
DAIS OKAY THANK YOU ARE BEFORE
I ASK YOU TO CLOSE AN A MORALE
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO WEIGH IN.
AS A MOTHER OF TWENTY SEVEN
YEAR OLD TWIN DAUGHTERS WHO HAD
SEX EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS- I DID NOT FEEL THAT IT
WAS NOT AGE APPROPRIATE I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY AS A PARENT. TO
REVIEW THE MATERIAL IF I WENT
INTO THE SCHOOL AND FOR IT
WHICH I BELIEVE ALL PARENTS
HAVE THAT RIGHT NOW. IF YOU DO
IF YOU DO NOT WANT YOUR CHILD
TO RECEIVE SEX EDUCATION I
WOULD BE VERY PROACTIVE AS A
PARENT I WOULD WALK TO THE
OFFICE THEN I WOULD SAY MY
DAUGHTER IS. OUR SON IS IN. YOU
KNOW WHAT. IT'S MY TURN TO
SPEAK NO AND IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT I WILL ASK
FOR THE SERGEANTS TO REMOVE
FEEL. IF I DID NOT MY CHILD. TO
RECEIVE SEX EDUCATION I WOULD
GO INTO THE OFFICE I WOULD
SPEAK TO THE PRINCIPLE. AND I
WOULD ASK THAT WHENEVER THE
TIME ARISES THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO TEACH SEX EDUCATION. BUT DID
NOT WANT MY CHILD TO BE A PART
OF THAT ALL. THEY MET WHICH
WOULD BE I UNDERSTAND. WE DID
NOT HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE AND
THAT'S WRONG. SEVERAL WE'VE
WORKED WITH YOU FOR A YEAR ON
THIS BILL- WE AGREE WITH YOU I
AGREE WITH YOU ON THE ONLINE IN
THE TRANSPARENCY PIECE A
HUNDRED PERCENT- WE OFFER TO
SOME AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ADDRESS TO SENATOR TO RASS
CONCERNS YOU ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN THOSE AND WE MADE A FAIR I
MADE IT VERY CLEAR. THAT THE
OPTIM PIECE WOULD MAKE IT
SOMETHING THAT I COULD NOT VOTE
ON I THINK THAT PARENTS SHOULD
BE INVOLVED IN THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION I WAS VERY INVOLVED
IN MY CHILDREN'S EDUCATION I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY FOLKS IN
THIS ROOM HAVE READ THE
EDUCATION MATERIAL THAT WOULD
BE PRESENTED VERY GOOD. THERE'S
NOTHING IN THERE THAT IS NOT
AGE APPROPRIATE. IF YOU. I
DON'T LIE I DON'T LIE YOU MAY
DISAGREE. I AM NOT IMMORAL AND
I AM NOT A LIAR IT JUST BECAUSE
WE THIS IS THE WRONG WITH THIS
IS WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE
DISCOURSE IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW
IF WE DON'T AGREE YOU CALL
PEOPLE A LIAR I HAVE NOT CAUGHT
DISAGREED WITH MANY OF YOU AND
I HAVEN'T CALLED ANY IF YOU A
LIAR. BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU'RE LYING. SO THERE IS
SOME THERE ARE SOME THINGS
GOING AROUND ONLINE THAT ARE
BEING PROPAGATES PROPAGATED BY-
SENATORS OR A SENATOR. IN THIS
BUILDING. AND IT SAYS THAT WE
ARE TEACHING ANAL SEX. SEXTING
CYBERSEX. PHONE SEX SENSATION
PLATE AND KINKY SEX. IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CURRICULUM. IT IS
NOT THERE. IT IS NOT THERE IT
IS NOT YOU WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
POINTING. THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
POINTING I SEE YOU. WHAT YOU'RE
POINTING OUT WAS REMOVED THAT
WAS A VERSION. OKAY WELL WE
HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT. IT'S NOT THERE
IT'S NOT BEING TAUGHT- I THINK
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS. IS
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO TALK TO
THEIR CHILDREN ABOUT SEX. AND.
THANK YOU. AND IT'S NOT
CONDESCENDING I KNOW BECAUSE I
AGE BOY BOY YOU GUYS OR
SOMETHING ELSE. CENTER AROUND
YOU CAN ASK YOUR WITNESSES TO
BE RESPECTFUL OF THE PROCESS
I'D ASK YOU TO BE RESPECT. I
DOUBTS IDEA I WOULD ASK YOU TO
BE RESPECTFUL BUT ALSO- THEIR
PARENTS YOU ARE LECTURING SO
I'M NOT LECTURING I'M GIVING MY
OPINION YOU KNOW WHAT BUT WE'RE
DONE I AM RECOMMENDING A NO
VOTE ON THE BILL SENATE MORALE
PLEASE CLOSE. THANK YOU SENATOR
LEYVA FOR A YEAR. LECTURE.
LISTEN I BOUGHT SOME OF THE
CURRICULUM. ON AMAZON BECAUSE
THEY HAD DIFFERENT RESOURCES
ALMOST I REMEMBER- DANTE'S
INFERNO THE SEVEN LAYERS OF
HELL YOU HAD TO REALLY WORK TO
THEIR CURRICULUM KEEP GOING
DOWN THEY HAD RESOURCE GUIDES
AND BOOKS THE BY THEN SUGGESTED
READING I BOUGHT THAT STUFF
AND- IT'S REALLY NOT AS YOU SAY
THAT STUFF IS IN THERE I I'VE
I'VE GOT IT I COULD. GET IF YOU
LIKE TO SEE THOSE PICTURES AND
YOUR VOTING WILL PASS IT HERE'S
MINE THIS THIS THIS BILL A NO
VOTE- TAKES PARENTS OUT OF THE
LOOP. I THINK IT'S
DISRESPECTFUL FOR AN ABSTENTION
BY THE WAY- BECAUSE YOU DON'T
THINK PARENTS SHOULD HAVE FULL
ACCESS EVEN THESE LETTERS THAT
WERE WRITTEN BELIEVE THAT
HAVING PARENTS SEE FULL
TRANSCRIPT PERRANCE SIENNA.
SCHOOL LESSONS THAT IS TOO MUCH
WORK TOO MUCH PROBLEM. THAT'S
WRONG AND- YES YOU DID NOT HELP
FOR ME AMENDMENT WHICH I WANT
TO THANK YOU BUT IT WAS TAKEN
THE OTHER HALF OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BILL AWAY
SO IT'S LIKE. YOU OFFERED ME.
WHICH I THANK YOU FOR THAT BUT
THEN YOU TO I GUESS THE STAKE
AWAY YOU KNOW WHICH WAS THE OP
DAN SO THAT'S WHY. IT WASN'T
THAT I WAS ON COOPER CAT I
JUST- I'M HERE TO SERVE THESE
PEOPLE AND THEY'VE ASKED ME NOT
TO COMPROMISE IN THIS BILL AND
NOT COMPROMISE OUR CHILDREN SO
THAT'S WHY I WAS UNABLE TO TAKE
YOUR MEMBERS BUT YOU KNOW I
SURE THERE WAS THE ONE PASTOR
WHO WHO TOLD PEOPLE STATE OUT
OF SCHOOL AND I'M A PRODUCT OF
THE- LEAST IN EARLY GRADES OF A.
SCHOOL AND- SOME WOULD SAY THE-
GOOD JOB OTHERS MAY SAY THEY
DIDN'T DO A GOOD JOB WITH ME
BUT- BUT I AM CONCERNED BECAUSE
DOCTOR SOBEL EVEN SAID EARLIER
HE'S SPOKEN TO PEOPLE OUTSIDE
BY THE WORK. THEY COULD BE AN
EXODUS OUT OF THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND OTHER PRIVATE
SCHOOLS AND HOME SCHOOLING-
KEEPING PEOPLE I WONDER HOW
MANY PEOPLE BASED ON WHAT THIS
OTHER PASTOR DEBT ARE GONNA-
YOU KNOW HAVE WEAKER DAY OUT OF
SCHOOL WHICH IS ONLY GONNA HURT
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND
SO I WANT TO SEE THAT IN AGAIN
I JUST CLOSE BY- IS SAYING YES
VOTE IS AGAIN GIVING PARENTS
FULL TRANSPARENCY PARENTS WHO
ARE THAT'S THEIR KIDS RIGHT AND.
AND THEY THE OFTEN IS THE I
THINK. YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT CAN
AGREE ON THAT BUT I THINK IT-
IT BULLET PROOFS AN ARM AND
AGAIN GIVES PARENTS GREATER
OPTION SO RESPECTFULLY- I DO
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND- I DO
LIKE- DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE A
LITTLE BIT CONTENTIOUS I. SORT
OF THRIVE ON OUT SO. THANK YOU
FOR BEING. PATIENT WITH ME
THANK YOU CENTER RELEVANT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SOMEONE I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TO MOVE THE BILL
OKAY. IS BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
WELCOME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL HIM ONE SB SIX SEVENTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA NO LEYVA
NO WILK HI WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D WRESTLE WITH US ON
BILL GLAZER GLAZER NO MCGUIRE
PAN. PAN NO. FOR KNOWS AND TO
YES VOTES AND WE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE
TO VOTE. SKINNER WHEN YOU GET
HERE WE WILL MOVE HERE BILL.
GREAT JOB. WE DID OUR BEST RATE.
THE PLEASE. THANK. WORK FOR ME
ONE. WE HAVE A SECOND
. I WILL
BE PRESENTING SENATOR SCANNERS
BILL FOR HER SO IF SOMEONE
CALLED CANNOT GIVE ME HER
TALKING POINTS THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL
. AND
. SEVEN SEVEN SIX.
ALL RIGHT UP NEXT IS ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX
BY SENATOR SKINNER- SHE'S AT
ANOTHER COMMITTEE HEARING SO-
IN HER PLACE WILL BE OUR
ILLUSTRIOUS CHAIR PRESENTING
THE RECOMMENDATION FOR THIS
BILL IS DUE PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK I GET TO HAVE ANY
TALKING POINTS- SO I WOULD
RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTES IF
SOMEONE WANTED TO MOVE THE
BILL. BUT YOU HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS RIGHT. WE HAVE A
LETTER TO PROCESS SO I CAN DIE
CAN DO THOSE OFF LINE AT A
LATER DATE OKAY VERY GOOD. I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
ANY HEAR ANYBODY HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. YES ALRIGHT
COME ON UP. CLEARLY ALL OF WHAT
MUCH MORE HERE. RULES RULES OF
COMMITTEE- TWO SPEAKERS AT TWO
MINUTES I SEE THREE IF YOU GUYS
WANT TO SPLIT THE FOUR MINUTES
THAT'S FINE. HELLO YEAH. ACTION
SO WE GET TO SPEAKERS. AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH GOING PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR IN
HONORABLE MIDI MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KISHA
MURPHY FROM THE TIME FOR CHANGE
FOUNDATION AND ROUTE TO REBOUND
I HAVE BEEN A LICENSED
VOCATIONAL NURSE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TEN ON ONE OF. ONE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
ONE CARE CERTIFY CLINICIANS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
ALSO FORMERLY INCARCERATED
WOMAN. I HAVE ATTAINED A
CERTIFICATE OR ABILITY TATIAN
TO THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SUPERIOR COURT IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
WEST COAST UNIVERSITY WHICH IS
A PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
INSTITUTION PURSUING MY
BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE DEGREE IN
NURSING IN THE WHERE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AFTER
ACCUMULATING- ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOANS. AND JUST SIX
MONTHS FIVE COMPLETING MY
DEGREE I WAS EXPELLED FROM
SCHOOL THE UNIVERSITY'S ETHICS
COMMITTEE REASON FOR MY
EXPULSION WAS THAT THEY FELT IT
WAS UNLIKELY THATI WOULD
OBTAIN LICENSOR AND EMPLOYMENT
POST GRADUATION BECAUSE OF MY
CRIMINAL HISTORY. GET I'M
ALREADY A LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSE EMPLOYED IN. THE DIGNITY
HEALTH HOSPITAL SYSTEM I CAN'T
TELL YOU THE HEARTBREAK I FELT
THERE WAS NO CONSIDERATION OF
MY PERFORMANCE AS A STUDENT THE
FACT THAT I EARNED A
CERTIFICATE A REHABILITATION OR
THE FACT THAT I'M CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED AS AN LPN. PEOPLE SAY
EDUCATION IS THE KEY TO PREVENT
INCARCERATION AND RECIDIVISM I
HAVE BEEN OUT FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
DURING THAT TIME I HAVE APPLIED
TO HAVE BEEN DENIED EMISSIONS
TO SIX SCHOOLS DURING MY DUE TO
MY PAST INCARCERATION I DIDN'T
GIVE UP I FINALLY FOUND A
SCHOOL THAT WOULD EMIT ME. I
FEEL THAT I HAVE FOUND MY
PURPOSE AND I WAS ON THE RIGHT
PATH SO I HOPE THAT YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE SENSE OF
DEVASTATION I FELT AFTER BEING
REJECTED YET AGAIN STAFF YEARS
OF FIGHTING FOR ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION STILL I WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR MY
EDUCATION AND A BETTER LIFE
WHICH IS WHY I'M HERE BEFORE
YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX. THERE ARE
MILLIONS OF OTHER PEOPLE LIKE
ME. SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX IS
URGENTLY NEEDED TO PREVENT POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS FROM
LOCKING OUT FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE SEEKING
HIGHER EDUCATION. IN ORDER TO
TRANSFORM THEIR LIVES THEIR
FAMILIES. AND BECOME TAX PAYING
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA'S INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO ACCEPT TITLE FOR
FUNDING. OUR PUBLIC TAX DOLLARS
AND THEN DENY OR WITHIN ACCESS
TO ACADEMICALLY QUALIFIED
STUDENTS ON ACCOUNT AND THEIR
CONVICTION HISTORY. WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME IS UNFAIR AND
SET BACK. SET ME BACK ON MY
JOURNEY. SEVEN SEVEN SIX WILL
PREVENT POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS FROM INFLICTING
THIS AND JUSTICE ON OTHERS
PLEASE VOTE. ON THE BILL SEVEN
SEVEN SIX AND BANNED THE BY THE
HIGHER EDUCATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
SORRY TO HEAR WHAT HAVE WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU THAT'S NOT
RIGHT. NEXT WITNESS MADAM
CHAIR- HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DOCTOR
BRADY HEINER- I'M A PROFESSOR
OF PHILOSOPHY IN THE FOUNDER
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
PROJECT REBOUND AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY FULLERTON. I'M ALSO
THE CHAIR OF THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM SO I ADDRESS YOU
TODAY AS A REPRESENTATIVE FOR
NINE PUBLICLY FUNDED PROGRAMS
AT CSU CAMPUSES. ACROSS THE
STATE. THE MISSION OF PROJECT
REBOUND IS TO SUPPORT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION AND SUCCESSFUL
REINTEGRATION OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM COME FROM
HISTORICALLY UNDER SERVED- AND
EDUCATIONALLY DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS. OUR PROGRAMS ARE
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL THE STUDENTS
IN OUR PROGRAMS 64% OF WHOM ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN OR LATINO. DO
NOT RETURN TO PRISON. AFTER
MORE THAN THREE YEARS OF
OPERATE IN. THE PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM HAS IS 0% RECIDIVISM
RATE. THIS IS ONE OF THE MANY
REASONS WHY GOVERNOR NEW SOME
IN THE STATE LEGISLATOR STATE
LEGISLATURE- ACTED LAST YEAR TO
INVEST IN THE CSU PROJECT
REBOUND CONSORTIUM. TO ALLOW US
TO SUSTAIN AND SCALE ARE PROVEN
MODEL OF SUCCESS. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVEN SIX IS
ESSENTIAL TO THE ACTUALIZATION
OF PROJECT REBOUNDS MISSION TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM INCREASE
STRONGER SAFER COMMUNITIES
THROUGH HIGHER EDUCATION.
BECAUSE THAT'S BE SEVEN SEVEN
SIX WOULD REMOVE A CRITICAL
BARRIER TO THE TRANSFORMATIVE
POWER OF HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED COLLEGE
AND UNIVERSITY APPLICANTS.
THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS DO
NOT REQUEST ARREST AND
CONVICTION HISTORY INFORMATION
IN UNDERGRADUATE ADMISSIONS.
HOWEVER THERE REMAINS A
WIDESPREAD ARBITRARY PATTERN OF
DENYING IN MISSION TO
ACADEMICALLY QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS WHO HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THIS PRACTICE PERSISTS AMONG
GRADUATE LEVEL PROGRAMS AT BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS AS
WELL AS PRIVATE UNDERGRADUATE
INSTITUTIONS. TWO MONTHS AGO AT
THE URGING OF CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY FULLERTON PRESIDENT
FRAM ROSE VERGY CSU CHANCELLOR
TIMOTHY WHITE HAND DELIVERED TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S OFFICE A
LETTER IN SUPPORT OF THE PARDON
OF MERE AMINI. MERE IS AN
ALUMNUS OF PROJECT REBOUND AND
pSTATE FULLERTON COMMUNITY. LAST
YEAR HE WAS AWARDED THE STEWARD
OF PLACE AWARD BY THE
UNIVERSITY CENTER FOR
INTERNSHIPS AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT FOR HIS WORK
MENTORING UNDERSERVED YOUTH IN
THE COMMUNITY. AND YET DESPITE
EARNING A THREE POINT SEVEN GPA
AND MANY OTHER ACCOLADES MERE
WAS TOLD BY THE MASTERS IN
COUNSELING PROGRAM AT CSU
DOMINGUEZ HILLS THAT BORDER TO
APPLY HE MUST PRESENT A
CERTIFICATE OF CLEARANCEFROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE A
CERTIFICATE YOU COULD NOT
PROVIDE DUE TO A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION FROM NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN. WHEN HE WAS JUST
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD. YOU'RE SAID
TO ME WHEN I WALKED IN FOR THAT
THE MASTER. PLAN PROGRAM AT CAL
STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS WOULD NOT
ADMIT ME DUE TO MY PAST IT HIT
ME LIKE A TON OF BRICKS. I FELT
LIKE ALL THAT I HAD
ACCOMPLISHED AT CSU FULLERTON
AND IN MY LIFE AFTER MY RELEASE
SEEM FEW TILE. LIKE MY PAST
WOULD ALWAYS PREVENT ME FROM
SERVING MY COMMUNITY AND LIVING
A PURPOSEFUL LIFE. FORTUNATELY
FOR ME AND HIS FAMILY MERE WILL
BECOME A FATHER NEXT MONTH AND
FORTUNATELY FOR ALL OF THE
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS WHO MAYOR
IS NOW DALY AND JOYFULLY
SERVING AT THE C. AS THE CSU
FULLERTON. PROJECT REBOUND
ENROLLMENT SPECIALIST. THE
MASTERS IN COUNSELING PROGRAM
AT CSU LONG BEACH DID NOT
UNJUSTLY BARRED MAYOR FROM
THEIR PROGRAM OR REQUIRE HIM TO
DISCLOSE HIS CRIMINAL HISTORY.
MERS CASE EXEMPLIFIES THE NEED
FOR SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVEN SIX.
IN ONE IN THE SAME CSU SYSTEM
YOU HAVE A STUDENT HO IS
RECEIVE THE HIGHEST
RECOMMENDATION NOT JUST FROM
HIS PROFESSORS BUT FROM HIS
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT AND THE
CSU CHANCELLOR HIMSELF. AND YET
ARBITRARY POLICIES MADE BY
PROFESSORS ARE ADMINISTRATORS
AND GRADUATE PROGRAMS ELSEWHERE
IN THE CSU LOCKED MERE OUT OF
THE LOGICAL NEXT STEP IN HIS
CAREER A CAREER THAT THE CSU
PREPARED HIM FOR. AT THE CSU
ADMINISTRATOR AND PROFESSOR I
AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE THE MOST
QUALIFIED PEOPLE TO JUDGE THE
ACADEMIC MERITS OF APPLICANTS
SEEKING ADMISSIONS- TO PROGRAMS
IN THE FIELDS OF OUR EXPERTISE.
HOWEVER THE LAW SHOULD NOT
ALLOW US TO CATEGORICALLY BAR
APPLICANTS WITH CRIMINAL
CONVICTION HISTORIES. RATHER
THE LAW SHOULD REQUIRE THAT
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS
GIVE ALL APPLICANTS A FAIR
CHANCE TO BE JUDGED ON THEIR
ACTED. THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICAN COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. ALL SUPPORT
BANNING THE BOX FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION MADAM CHAIR-
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE ASK THAT YOU
PLEASE VOTE BY ON SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVEN SIX SO THE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS LIKE
MERE. FOR ACADEMICALLY
QUALIFIED RECEIVED A FAIR
CHANCE AT HIGHER EDUCATION THAT
ALL OF US DESERVE DOING SO WILL
HELP BUILD SAFER AND STRONGER.
COMMUNITIES AND A STRONGER
ECONOMY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S ALSO THE RIGHT
THING TO DO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. NAME IF YOU WITH AN
ORGANIZATION AND THEN THAT YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS CHLOE NEWNAN I'M
HERE TODAY FROM WRITTEN REBOUND
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS A
MEAN L. STURM UNDERGRAD UC
BERKELEY INFORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENT LEADER OF
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ALEXANDER CALDER'S
HOBBY HAVE MYSELF STUDENT
ALANIS OF SACRAMENTO CA AND
GRADUATES TO NOT UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MY NAME'S
NOR BEST I'M A- DOCTOR ARE A
POSTDOCTORAL RESEARCH FELLOW AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY- ALSO WORK
FOR ON LIKE HIGHER EDUCATION-
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
AND I LIVE IN PALO ALTO THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME SKINNER
JOHNSON I'M WITH SEKHEMRE STATE
PROJECT REBOUND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. HELLO MY
NAME IS MIGUEL GARCIA ON THE
POLICY COORDINATOR FOR THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM AM PROUD ALUMNI FOR
UC RIVERSIDE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS CANDOR BARNES I AM A
MASTER OF SOCIAL WORK STUDENT
AT SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY
AND A FORMER ALLOW AT SEE IT
AT. SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS IN CHAIR AS A
RECENT GRADUATE FROM UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA DAVIS AS WELL AS A
DAUGHTER NIECE AND SISTER TO.
FORMALLY AND CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED FOLKS I STRONGLY
ASKS YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS
SKYLER GM UNDERGRAD IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND CURRENTLY A GRAD
STUDENT SOCIAL RECOGNIZE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. GOOD MORNING
HELLO MY NAME IS LOCATION
THOMPSON I AM A GRAD STUDENT IN
SOCIAL WORK AND I'M ALSO A
FOSTER PARENT FOR A LOT OF AT
RISK YOUTH AND I STRONGLY.
PLEASE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS HERE IN
PHOENIX AND I'M A CASE MANAGER
FOR TIME FOR CHANGE FOUNDATION
ALSO FORMALLY INCARCERATED-
MOTHER OF ONE AND GRANDMA AND
MOTHER OF FOUR. I STRONGLY-
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I SURE
HOPE YOU GUYS TO AS WELL. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS CARLA KARACHI
I'M A CLIENT AT TIME FOR CHANGE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND I
STRONGLY. SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S ANDREW
WHEN I'M INFORMING CARCERI
GRADUATE STUDENT COFOUNDER
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS AT UCLA
AND CURRENT DIRECTOR PROCTOR
REBOUNDED SECOND ST NASH FROM
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION. OKAY PLEASE
COME FORWARD. SO THE PROPONENTS
WENT OVER A LITTLE BIT SO I
WILL GIVE YOU UP TO FIVE
MINUTES. OKAY. JUSTTRYING TO
BE IS APPLICABLES POSSIBLE SO.
AND WHENEVER YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
GO AHEAD AND PROCEED. AREA
SORRY I'M ALEX GRAVES THE
ASSOCIATION INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WE REPRESENT
EIGHTY FIVE INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE- WE
DON'T HAVE A FORMAL OPPOSE
POSITION RIGHT NOW WE'VE BEEN
ASSESSING THE PROPOSAL IN THE
LAST WEEK SINCE THE LANGUAGES
INTERVIEWS BUT WE DID WANT TO
SHARE. AT LEAST ONE OF OUR
CONCERNS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
THINK THROUGH WITH OUR
INSTITUTIONS- I THINK THE
ANALYSIS HIGHLIGHTS THE
LICENSURE COMPLEXITY WITH THIS
I WON'T FOCUS ON THAT BUT I DID
WANT TO RAISE- SOMETHING
REGARDING ACCREDITATION. THEY
WERE THINKING ABOUT SO FOR MANY
OF OUR- GRADUATE DEGREE
PROGRAMS ADVANCED DEGREES-
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT IN
ACCREDITATION STUDENTS HAVE TO
DO A COUPLE ROTATION SO THIS IS
FOR THINGS LIKE PHYSICIAN'S
ASSISTANT CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGY
NURSING DENTAL PROGRAMS FAMILY
COUNSELING- MEDICINE SOCIAL
WORK. AND YES. SO OFTEN TIMES
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT- DEPENDING
ON WHAT IS IN THAT- STUDENTS
BACKGROUND- THOSE. FACILITIES
THAT WERE PARTNERING WITH FOR
THESE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS WON'T
TAKE STUDENTS WITH CERTAIN-
THINGS THAT MIGHT SHOW UP IN
THOSE I KNOW I SHOULD SAY THAT.
THE QUESTION AROUND- CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS WHAT HAVE YOU
WAS NOT AN AUTOMATIC
DISQUALIFIER RATHER OUR
INSTITUTIONS ARE THAN TRYING TO
LOOK AND SEE WHAT IT IS IN THAT
BACKGROUND AND IF. THEY FOR
WHATEVER'S FLAG IN THAT IS
SOMETHING LIKELY TO MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THEM TO PLACE
THE STUDENTS IN THAT CLINICAL
ROTATION. BECAUSE OUT WITH THEN
WE WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE
ENROLLING STUDENTS IN THE
ABSENCE OF BEING ABLE TO KIND
OF HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
FIGURE THIS OUT. BE ENROLLING
STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM A. B.
IN ORDER TAKE OUT LOANS TO PAY
THAT TUITION FOR GRADUATE
PROGRAMS THAT THEN WE CAN NOT.
LIKELY ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
COMPLETE THE PROGRAM- AND GET
THAT DEGREE AND GO ON TO GET A
JOB SO- YOU KNOW IN TALKING
WITH OUR INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS
LIKE WESTERN UNIVERSITY HEALTH
SCIENCES IN THE POMONA AREA
CHICAGO SCHOOL OF PROFESSIONAL
PSYCHOLOGY LOS ANGELES- LOMA
LINDA UNIVERSITY- WE ARE.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW THIS
MIGHT IMPACT THAT- AND YOU KNOW
WE WOULD LIKE TO- EXPLORE- AND
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE- ABOUT HOW WE
MIGHT ADDRESS THAT NEW ONES SO
THAT WE ARE NOT- PUTTING
STUDENTS KNOW PROGRAM HAVING
SIR AGAIN TO PAY AND TAKE OUT
LOANS FOR THESE PROGRAMS IF WE
CAN'T- PRESUME THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY COMPLETE THAT. GOING
INTO THE WORKFORCE WITH THAT
DEGREE. ANY ANYBODY STE THE
MOVIE ANYBODY ELSE- IN
OPPOSITION. I'M ON A DATE AT
SIXTEEN SEVEN A QUESTION FOR
YOU SO TO ME THAT QUESTION IS
ABOUT THE LICENSURE BUREAU
WHATEVER BUT YOU'RE SAYING.
BASED UPON POTENTIALLY RESPONSE
SOMEBODY'S BACKGROUND THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO DO THE
CLINICAL WORK AND WHAT IN
PARTICULAR OFFICE IN CERTAIN
FACILITIES. RIGHT THAT THAT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING AND TALKING
WITH OUR INSTITUTIONS AND- YOU
KNOW I AM STILL TRYING TO
GATHER MORE INFORMATION ON THAT
BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ADVANCED DEGREE PROGRAMS LIKE
THE ONES I MENTIONED WHERE THE
ACCREDITING BODY- WHICH I THINK
FOR ALL THAT MIGHT BE WHY ASK-
REQUIRES AS PART OF THE
ACADEMIC PROGRAM FOR
ACCREDITATION TO HAVE- SIR
NUMBER OF HOURS RIGHT NOW
CLINICAL SETTING. THANK YOU
SIR. AT THIS POINT A PULL BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU AND- THE SOMEONE WHO
ACTUALLY WAS IN CHARGE OF A
POST GRADUATE PROGRAM I WAS A
RESIDENCY DIRECTOR- AND TAKE
SOME RESPONSIBILITY OVER ALSO
MEDICAL STUDENTS I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERN I JUST WANNA
CLARIFY IN RELATION TO THIS
BILL THOUGH. WHAT THIS BILL
SAYS YOU CAN'T USE OUR ASK
ABOUT CRIMINAL HISTORY ON THE
INITIAL APPLICATION. BUT AFTER
REVIEW YOU DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY POTENTIALLY.
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND I HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW THE
DESIRES ACTUALLY TO DO AS
NEARLY AS POSSIBLE- THAT BEFORE
YOU ACTUALLY OFFER ADMISSION.
AT THAT POINT YOU CAN. ASK
ABOUT THE CRIMINAL HISTORY IS
THAT I UNDERSTAND THAT'S THE
NATURE OF THE NATURE OF THE WAY
THE BILL'S STRUCTURE IS THAT
CORRECT. THE CURRENT LANGUAGE
OF WOULD RESTRICT POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS FROM
ASKING ABOUT CRIMINAL HISTORY-
AT ANY POINT IN THE APPLICATION
PROCESS UP UNTIL THE FINAL
DETERMINATION. OKAY SO JUST TO
CLARIFY THOUGH BEFORE YOU
ACTUALLY OFFER ADMISSION. YOU
CAN ASK BEFORE YOU MAKE THE
FINAL DECISION CORRECT OKAY HI
I JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT'S
CLEAR BECAUSE I THINK THAT-
HOPEFULLY ADDRESSES THE CONCERN
OF THE INDEPENDENT REVERSED I
MEAN THIS IS THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
A LARGER CONVERSATION WE NEED
TO HAVE ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHICH
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE APPROPRIATE
AND SO FORTH BUT THEN WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CLINICAL
EDUCATION. IT'S NO DID THEN
WE'D CERTAINLY WANT TO GIVE
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO
STUDENTS- SAME TIME THAT THEY
CAN'T GET LICENSED IF- FOR SOME
REASON AND- SOMETIMES IT'S EVEN
STATE LAW THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO
NOT HAVE CERTAIN TYPES OF
CONVICTIONS- TO BE L. IT ALONE
WITH A PATIENT OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. YEAH WE HAVE TO FEET
WE HAVE TO WORK THAT PART OUT
BUT WE CAN'T DO LIKELY A
SITUATION I THINK IS PRESENTED
WHERE YOU HAVE A STUDENT WHO
START TO PROGRAM IS AT FORTY
UNABLE TO ACTUALLY COMPLETE THE
PROGRAM. YET YOU KNOW AND GET
THE BENEFIT OF THAT EDUCATION
BECAUSE OF- OF SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WOULD BE NOT FAIR TO THE
STUDENT ACTUALLY FOR THEM NOT
TO BE AWARE OF THAT SITUATION.
PRIOR TO THAT- PRIOR TO
ADMISSION SURE A MAN AND MY
COLLEAGUE AT RESPONSE. I'M
HELLO THANK YOU MY NAME IS
SONYA THOMAS AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH WRITTEN REBOUND.
I'M I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
THAT- THAT CONVICTION HISTORY
INFORMATION IS NOT TO BE USED
UP UNTIL THE FINAL DECISION AND
MISSIONS. ON THE BILL DOES NOT
TOUCH ON ANYTHING RELATED TO
DISCIPLINARY RECORDS SO THAT
CAN STILL BE UTILIZED BY A
SCHOOLS. ON THE BELIEVE WHICH
SENATOR WILL Q. ALLUDED TO IS
THAT ADMISSIONS DEPARTMENTS ARE
NOT PROPERLY SITUATED OR
PREPARED TO PROVIDE THE LEGAL
ADVICE THAT'S NECESSARY. FOR
STUDENTS PURSUING LICENSURE-
THERE. IS A BELIEF THAT THAT
SHOULD BE HANDLED BY ADVISING
WITHIN SCHOOLS WHO ARE PROPERLY
TRAINED ADVISORS WHO UNDERSTAND
LICENSURE AND THE VERY RAPIDLY
CHANGING LICENSURE
REQUIREMENTS. I ALSO WANTED TO
ADD THAT A COMPLICATING FACTOR
AND I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE HERE
I'M SPEAKING ON ON ABOUT THOSE
CONCERNS AND WE SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS A COMPLICATING FACTORS
THAT LICENSURE VARIES BY EVERY
STATE. I'M SO THE ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION OFTEN IS
LEADING TO PROFESSIONS THAT THE
PERSON MAY OR MAY NOT BE
LICENSE AS A LICENSED LAWYER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I HAVE
LAWYERS WHO ARE ON MY TEAM ARE
NOT LICENSED. BEFORE YOU ARE
FULLY ABLE TO DO THEIR JOB- SO
I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS. BILL IS IT'S CLEAR THAT
IT'S DEAL WITH IT. AND UP UNTIL
THE FINAL DECISION AND THAT
LAYS INJURED BY SHOULD BE
HANDLED SEPARATELY. THANK YOU
YEAH I THINK HE WANTED WAY IN.
YEAH AND I MEAN IS I IS WE READ
THE BILL- SUBSECTION BE WHEN IT
SAYS OR AT ANY TIME DURING THE
ADMISSION PROCESS BEFORE THE
INSTITUTIONS FINAL DECISION
RELATIVE TO THE PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS APPLICATION FOR
ADMISSION. WE READ THAT
INTERPRET THAT IS IT WE CANNOT
ASK UNTIL A FINAL
DETERMINATION. AFTER A FINAL
DETERMINATION PERMISSION IS
BEEN MADE AND IF THAT'S NOT THE
END TEN WE LOVE TO. CLARIFY
THAT. BUT THAT THAT'S HOW WE
READ THE BILL. SO AGAIN MY
QUESTION IS TO THE SPONSORS IS
DO WE HAVE A LEASE AGREEMENT
AND CONCEPTS OF THAT. THAT THE
SCHOOL SHOULD BE ABLE TO PASS.
THE PARTICULARLY FOR
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH YOU KNOW
THEIR EDUCATION MAY REQUIRE
THAT- MAYBE LIMITED BECAUSE-
BASICALLY TO ASK ABOUT CRIMINAL
HISTORY PRIOR TO ACTUALLY
MAKING E. L. WELTS BEFORE THE
ACTUAL- FINAL DECISION BECAUSE
IT'S BEFORE MAKING THE OFFER
RIGHT YOU CAN'T MAKE A DECISION
TO ADMIT AND THEN. THE DENTAL
SO I MEAN. I GOT THE LIKE
INITIAL APPLICATION BUT THE-
BUT THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY AT-
FOR A DECISION HIGHER
EDUCATION- TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO REQUESTS AND REVIEW
INFORMATION PRIOR TO THEIR-
FUND FINAL DECISION FOR
ADMISSION. OKAY YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT YEAH HI YET THANK YOU
KATRINA ROBINSON FROM CENTER
SKINNER STAFF THANK YOU MISTER
SENATOR PAN FOR YOUR QUESTION I
JUST WANTED TO QUICKLY CLARIFY
FROM. FROM THE AUTHORS OFFICE-AND THANK YOU FOR INDULGING
THAT NONTRADITIONAL
PRESENTATION TODAY- BUT- THE
CURRENT TAX THE BILL DOES READ
THAT YOU CANNOT CONSIDER THE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED STATUS
OF THE INDIVIDUAL- UNTIL A
DETERMINATION IS MADE ON AND ON
ADMISSION. OF THING WITH OUR
SPONSORS AND- SOME THE GROUPS
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN NEGOTIATIONS
OR TO EARLY DISCUSSIONS WITH-
THAT HAVE HAD QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE BILL WHETHER OR AT WHAT
POINT THERE SHOULD POTENTIALLY
BE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
ACCREDITATION OR- OR
REQUIREMENTS THAT THE SCHOOL
HAS- ON THOSE TYPES OF HIGHER
EDUCATION- DEGREES. BUT I THINK
THIS IS THAT WE HAVE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY FORMAL OPPOSITION YES
WE ARE AN EARLY DISCUSSIONS
WITH PARTIES- TO DETERMINE
WHETHER LOS COULD TRULY DOES
REQUIRE- CERTAIN TYPES OF
FACILITIES TO- BE THE ONES THAT
ARE- INTERACTING WITH THE
STUDENTS OR IF IT'S JUST THAT
THE ABILITY THE SCHOOL PARTNERS
WITH. HAS A RESTRICTION BECAUSE
IT'S DEFECTIVE WALK
ACCREDITATION REQUIRES IT
VERSUS THE SCHOOL THE
INDIVIDUAL DEMONSTRATIONS ALSO
IT FOR SO WHY ASK ISN'T THE
ONLY. TREPIDATION BODY SO I
GUESS. BE CAREFUL ABOUT THAT I
THINK. THE AND THE I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THIS THE AYE AYE AYE AYE
A NOT INTERESTED IN TRYING TO
PREVENT PEOPLE WHO HAVE A
HISTORY OF INCARCERATION FROM
BEING ABLE TO YOU KNOW BE ABLE
TO THE SICKLY PURSUE WHAT THEY
WANT TO TRY PURSUE I DO THINK
THAT THE- AND BIG HAULAGE IS I
MEAN THERE THERE IS SERVICE
THERE ARE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH- IF. THE STUDENT IS NOT.
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
RELATIONSHIPS THEY HAVE AND
AGAIN THIS IS. MEET THE SECOND
FOR THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS NOT
ALL OF YOUR TRAINING SITES ANY
OF CONTRACTS AND RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEM BUT THEY'RE NOT
ENTIRELY IN YOUR OWN CONTROL
RIGHT. SO AND I'LL TELL YOU
THAT I WAS IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE ACTUALLY BECAUSE A-
POTENTIAL CLINICAL SITE
ACTUALLY HAD STANDARDS THAT WE
DISAGREE WITH YOU CHOSE NOT TO.
CONTACT WITHOUT THAT'S
UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH IT'S NOT
EASY TO FIND CLINICAL SITES IN
FACT THAT'S BEEN GETTING MORE
MORE DIFFICULT OVER TIME
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPETITION
FOR THEM. AND SO THE CHALLENGE
THERE IS THAT. IT IT SO IT'S
NOT THE UNIVERSITY IT'S ABOUT
IF I AM LIKE YOU HAVE TO DO A
CLINICAL ROTATION AN ACCIDENT
OR FOR YOU TO BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE NOR FREEDIA LICENSE
WHATEVER ELSE OKAY SO. AND THE
ONLY THE CLINICAL SAY THAT WE
HAVE. FOR WHATEVER REASONS SAYS
THAT WE WILL NOT ALLOW. YEAH
ANYONE WHO HAS CERTAIN TYPE OF
CONVICTION TO BE LET'S SAY
ALONG WITH THE PATIENT OR
WHATEVER AS FOR PATIENT
PROTECTION PURPOSES. NOW WE MAY
OR MAY NOT DISAGREE OR DISAGREE
ABOUT TAT BUT THAT'S THE- ONLY
SITE THEY HAVE ARE ALL THEIR
SITES HAVE THAT THAT KIND OF
RULE ORDER MAY EVEN BE A STATE
LAW HAS SENDS THEM SOMETHING WE
ACTUALLY REGULATION. THEN IT'S
NOT FAIR TO THE STUDIO FAIR TO
THE STUDENTS THAT WE ADMIT YOU
PROGRAM BUT YOU ACTUALLY CAN'T
COMPLETED BECAUSE WE CAN'T
PROVIDE YOU. THE KIND OF
TRAINING YOU NEED THAT WILL
ALLOW YOU TO COMPLETE ALL YOUR
REQUIREMENTS. THAT SO WITH THAT
I THINK THAT'S THE PART THAT.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS. AND SIX-
AND THAT'S WHY SAYING THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
OPPORTUNITY BEFORE YOU ACTUALLY
OPERATE MISSION BECAUSE WE
CAN'T BE BASICALLY WHEN YOU
OFFER MISSION YOU'RE PROMISING
SOMEONE YOU CAN. HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY GRADUATE AND IF YOU
CAN. THAT'S NOT FAIR EITHER.
YES I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN
FOR DEFINITELY AND I THINK WHAT
WHAT I'M JUST SAYING HERE IS-
FROM AUTHORS OFFICE WERE TRYING
TO PARSE LICENSING. AND
GRADUATION AND ACCREDITATION
THAT YOU NEED FOR GRADUATION
AND YES WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE
THAT GET ENROLLED IN A PROGRAM
THAT THEY CAN'T GRADUATE FROM
BECAUSE OF RESTRICTIONS-
LICENSING HOWEVER IS CHANGING
RAPIDLY AND PEOPLE WHO GRADUATE
WITH A GRADUATE DEGREE MAY NOT
ACTUALLY WANT TO PURSUE. A
LICENSE IN THE CREW THEY MAY
WANT IT FOR ANOTHER PURPOSE SO
WE'RE JUST PARK IN THOSE TWO
DISCUSSIONS AND YES WE DO PLAN
TO. FIGURE OUT HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE ACCREDITATION AND ACTUALLY
BEING ABLE TO GRADUATE PIECE.
AND WE JUST REQUESTED THE
INDULGENCE OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE GROUPS THAT HAVE
REACHED OUT RELATIVELY RECENTLY
OKAY SO IS THERE A COMMITMENT
THAT. SCHOOLS THEY HAVE
REASONABLE REASON TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY REVIEW THE CRIMINAL
HISTORY RECORD BEFORE THEY-
MAKE THE FINAL ADMISSION
DECISION OFFERED MISSION. WHILE
NOT BEING THE MEMBER. HERE
TODAY. I HOPE YOU'LL UNDERSTAND
THAT I CAN JUST SAY WE DO PLAN
TO CONTINUE THOSE CONGRESS. MAY
I ALSO FROM- AGAIN BRADY HIGHER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM. TO EXAMPLE SO IN
THE CASE OF THE- THE STUDENT
HOME I MENTIONED- THE PROGRAM
REQUIRED THEY HAD TO TRACK SAID
A TRACK OF COUNSELING THAT WENT
INTO THE K. THROUGH TWELVE
SYSTEM AND A TRACK THAT WAS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND OUR
STUDENT WAS INTERESTED IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COUNSELING
TRACK- AND THERE IS IN THE IN
THE EDUCATION CODE RESTRICTION
FOR FOLKS GOING INTO CASTING
THE K. TO TWELVE BUT THEY WERE
APPLYING BUT AND THERE IS NOT
IN HIGHER EDUCATION BUT THERE
WERE OF APPLYING A REQUIRING A
CERTIFICATE OF CLEARANCE. FOR
ALL APPLICANTS REGARDLESS OF
WHICH TRACK THEY WERE GOING
INTO- AND THEN ANOTHER EXAMPLE
OF ARNOLD TREVINO WHOSE- MSW-
GRADUATE AND PROJECT REBOUND
ALARM WHO- WAS AT FRESNO STATE
AND- IN IN HIS CASE AND IN MANY
CASES LIKE HIS- HE GOT A CALL
FROM. THE PROGRAM- THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO- WITH WITHDRAW
HIM FROM THE PROGRAM BECAUSE
THEY WERE HAVING DIFFICULTY
FINDING. AN INTERNSHIP SITE FOR
HIM TO DO AS PRACTICUM- BUT IN
THAT INSTANCE IT WAS JUST THE
CASE OF A OF AN INTERNSHIP
COORDINATOR WHO AFTER TWENTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE JUST DIDN'T
HAVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH SITES
THAT WOULD AND THERE WAS NO
LEGAL RESTRICTION THERE IT WAS
A- IT WAS A PERSONAL DECISION
ON THE PART OF- THE THOSE
SITES- SO FORTUNATELY PROJECT
REBOUND. WAS FOUNDED AT THAT
THE VERY SAME TIME THAT HE
RECEIVED THAT CALL IN TWO DAYS
LATER HE RECEIVED A CALL FROM
PROJECT REBOUND WHO WHO HAVE
NOW THEY HAVE FIVE DIFFERENT
SITES FOR SOCIAL WORK STUDENTS-
PROJECT REBOUND STUDENTS TO DO
THAT PRACTICUM WORK SITES WHICH
WILL WHICH WILL ALLOW THEM. TO
GET THAT EXPERIENCE SO IN MANY
CASES IT'S ABOUT AND THAT'S
PART OF WHAT PROJECT REBOUNDS
DOZEN THE CSU IS TRYING TO
BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS TO
MAKE THAT THAT TRAINING
POSSIBLE. THANK YOU OUR REAL
QUICK YES I WITH MY SITUATION
WEST COAST RAN EIGHT BACKGROUND
CHECKS. AND I. I CURRENTLY WORK
FOR DIGNITY HEALTH AS AN
EMPLOYEE WHICH THEY'RE ALSO
PARTNER WITH. I THOUGHT HELP
FROM ROUTE REBOUND THEY CONTACT
THE WEST BECAUSE I GOT BACK IN
SCHOOL SO NOW I GRADUATE NEXT
WEEK'S SO. THANK YOU THANK YOU-
JUST TO SPEAK ON THAT LIKE THE
THEME OF MY APPLICATION IS AT
THE BR INTO AS OF THIS MOMENT
SO LICENSING DOESN'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH OBTAINING
BACKGROUND CHECKS AND WEST
BECAUSE IT DID PERFORM. UPON
EMISSION IT THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF ME BEING THERE IS
JUST PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM
CAUGHT THEM TO SAY YOU SENT TO
SOMEONE ELSE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED. THEY SAID NO WE
DIDN'T AN EX BALTIMORE. SO IS
THERE'S NO TALK BETWEEN THE
SCHOOLS AND THE LICENSING THEY
FEEL AND THIS ON THEIR WEBSITE
IS UNLIKELY FOR ME TO BE
LICENSE IN IS UNLIKELY FOR ME
TO ATTAIN EMPLOYMENT AFTER
GRADUATION. IN WHICH I'M
ALREADY LICENSES AND THEY'LL BE
IN AN ALREADY WORK FOR THEIR
CLINICAL PARTNERS. THANK YOU
SIR PAN ANYTHING ELSE. NO. OKAY
PITY ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. SING NOW I'M LOOKING
FOR A MOTION AGAIN THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED HERE PRO SMACK
CLOSE I'M YEAH ONE IN MOTION
THEM CALLING YOU CLOSE WHICH IS
AGES OF FINAL COMMENT FOR ME
CONCEPTUALLY HI I UNDERSTAND
THE CONCEPT IN SUPPORT OF IT.
HERE FROM THE OPPOSITION-
YOU'RE BLESSED SAY YOU'RE GOING
TO BE DEALING WITH THE DEATH
DILIGENT AUTHOR SO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND WITH
WITH THE HOPE AND EXPECTATION
THAT EVERYTHING GETS WORKED OUT
WITH THAT. I'M SURE YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THINGS
HAPPEN FOR A REASON AND I'M
ACTUALLY THRILLED THAT I GOT TO
PRESENT THIS BILL AND BE HERE
TODAY- KISHA MURPHY IS- ONE OF
TEAM LATEST FAVORITE PEOPLE AND
WHEN WE FOUND OUT THE INJUSTICE
IT HAPPENED HER WE WROTE
LETTERS OF SUPPORT- AS DID
OTHER ELECTED IN OUR OUR
REGION. I VIEW THIS BILL AS A
SMALL STEP IN A MUCH BIGGER
PROBLEM AND THE BIGGER PROBLEM
IS THAT WE PEOPLE ARE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE MAKE A
MISTAKE THEY GET INCARCERATED
THEY GET OUT AND THEY PAID
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY AND THEN
WE DON'T ALLOW THEM TO BE
BETTER AND WE DON'T ALLOW THEM
TO HAVE A JOB AND SUPPORT
THEMSELVES WE WONDER WHY THE
RECIDIVISM RATE IS SO HIGH. SO
I SEE THIS BILL IS A SMALL STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION I THINK
THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK WE CAN
DO IN THIS AREA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WITH THAT. YES CENTER
CHIANG MAI THE MOTION. WITH
THAT CALL THE ROLL ITEM TWO SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA
HI LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK I
CHIANG CHIANG I'D LASSELL
GLAZER. PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE
PAN. I'LL BUT I BUT I'M THAT.
GUY THAT IT IT'S AN I HAVE BUT
I DO EXPECT TO SEE YEAH SINCE
SOME MODIFICATIONS WHEN I. FIVE
ON CALL. CONGRATS BY VOTERS OUT
WE'RE LEAVING ON CALL FOR OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT HERE HE DID
A GREAT JOB REPRESENTING CENTER
SCARE YOU GUYS DID A GREAT JOB.
YEAH YEAH. DEMOCRATIC. THANKS
YEAH YEAH. SOMEONE
. WE ARE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE ON. A
COMMITTEE RULES- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ME RULES WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I ADVISED HER VOTING I FIVE
ZERO GLAZER. PLEASE OUR EYES
SIX. THANK YOU WE'RE NOW GOING
TO OPEN THE ROLE ON SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM TO SB
SEVEN SEVEN SIX THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I FIVE ZERO TO WRESTLE.
WRESTLE AYE MCGUIRE. THANK YOU
WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL AS
WELL. THANK YOU MARIA ELENA
. WE
ARE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE
FIRST ON THE SENATE RULES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MANY ROLES WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
SENTENCING THE RULES HAVE BEEN
APPROVED SEVEN TO ZERO WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO ITEM ONE WHICH IS
SB SIX SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM ONE SB SIX
SEVENTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS OF THE
CHAIR VOTING NO VICE CHAIR
VOTING I'D- FIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
IS FIVE TWO TWO OR TWO TO FIVE.
EARLY. OKAY I WANT TO CHECK
THAT BILL FAILS WHICH SENATOR
MCGUIRE DID YOU YES IN ADVERT
LEVO WRONG. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ONCE AGAIN
ITEM ONE SB SIX SEVEN THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING NO VICE CHAIR VOTING I
TWO TO FOUR. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE NO
YOU'RE WELCOME. YOU TO FIVE. OF
FIVE NO VOTES TO YES VOTES THAT
BILL FAILS. ITEM TO SB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM TO SB SEVEN SEVEN SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I BY SERVING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE THE BILL
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
EVERYONE WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED